it's because i'm trying to get participants by this friday i
listen i have i had a week to organize you are already i had
something wrong with it no no it's because i've had to or
i've been trying to organize i had a week to organize this i
had a week to organize this so i've been like i've been like
it's just me and you and nobody else no i have five other
teams confirmed i have five other teams confirmed i'm just
oh you didn't say that okay well it's not like no you guys
are not like the second team you're not like you're not like
it's just me and you guys like it's i mean that's what i
thought no no no no i have five teams it's like it's like 10
teams and i have and you have five and i have five confirmed
and you guys could be the right you guys can be the It'll be
so fun.
I'll join if Mint joins.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, Stuffy.
No, Stuffy.
Stuffy, do you have you joined?
Are you busy on?
Stuffy, are you busy on Friday?
What?
Are we going trick or free?
Yeah, technically.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
All right, Stuffy, are you busy on Friday?
Do you have anything going on on Friday?
Oh, my God.
No one.
Oh, do you want to join an Apex tournament?
I'm hosting on it.
Oh, that was the worst thing.
You're busy.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's like, it's not.
There's no not a lot of shooting involved.
It's like there's hide-and-seek and there's like mid-lay
only Wait, that sounds kind of cute though Yes, it is Do you
want to do that Do you want to do I want to spend my Friday
doing it?
Yeah, and then yeah, and then it'll be like yeah, you mid
and live can be on a team together and then I'm cooking
yakini Ku the day.
Yeah, yeah, but no, no, no, but it's before it's before yak.
I saw your schedule.
It's before yakini Ku oh my god before yakuniku don't worry
man i made i made shirts it's at 1 p.m pst 1 p.m pst so it's
like nine in the middle of a day oh jose that's what that's
control resident day you're asking a lot of our friendship
oh you are not there's no way you're not even playing it on
that day you haven't finished control yet yeah not me lime
lime it's it's me but you can do it after you can play it
okay after you think this 10 player apex tournament isn't
going to take like no it's gonna be like three hours three
hours how long does it take man no no there's several game
modes there's several game modes it'll be three hours
maximum are you playing like crab game if it was apex what
does that mean like essentially like if crab game was an
apex basically what and guys i'll i'll join if mint joins
what do you win you can win potentially three grand per game
you can win a sense of pride and accomplishment i haven't
launched apex in years guys guys it'll be so fun guys guys
are you playing doki or are you just organizing no i'm i'm
playing too but don't worry don't worry i won't i won't kill
you guys because I'll be on our team.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We're on the same team.
I'll team with you guys.
I'll team out.
You just gotta let me know what characters you're playing
and I'll make sure we can like link up, you know?
We can all be in a call.
We can all be on the call.
We can all be in a call and then I'll be like, where are you
guys?
And I'll meet up with you guys at an area.
Yeah, hide and seek is about hiding from each other.
Well, I'm the seeker.
So like, I'll join if I can play Mirage and nothing but
Mirage.
Yeah, you can play Mirage.
Yes, that you can play Mirage.
You can play whatever the fuck you want, guys.
You can't even know the name of an apex caveman.
Ha ha.
Hi, Tom.
Guys, I swear you'll be so fun, guys.
You're going to have the...
What's his name?
That's not even...
That's from Overwatch.
That's from looking Overwatch, man.
Well, I'm on this.
We can...
I can, like, sub in and out, too.
Like, if you...
What do you mean...
You can sub in and out.
I would like, you know, if one of you guys need to rest for
a game, I can cop in.
Wait, what?
Again, we're not going to be playing together?
No, I thought this was like we're all going to be competing,
like, like Hunger Games.
Each game is, each, each team is only three people.
So that's why I'm saying you, you, Min, and Lime all
together, like a family.
Where are you?
I'm on the other team.
what can i do about that what can i do what are you family
you're basically roping in lambs to the slaughter no no no
no no no there's some people here who has never ever touched
apex so they're like they're like below they're like below
you guys but then there's people like you here who have i
will be restricted i will be restricted to melee only like i
can't do anything either i can only punch you are you all
gonna like are you all gonna get punched by me there's no
way i can i don't i don't trust it we're good you're
literally you're you're throwing us in there it's like
sandbag no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no No, no, no, no, that's not
how it's going to happen, guys.
That's not how it's going to happen.
If I see in the kill feed, if I see your name, and it was me
that punched you guys out, I'll let you guys rest each
other.
You could just say you could just not punch us, right?
I won't know until I knock you down.
Until I see you in the kill feed.
So I can only, yeah, you can only see people's names when
they're engaging the fight.
down and I'll see your name in the kill feed and then I'll
and then I'll run I'll leave you guys and then you guys
don't look I would look every guy I kill I'll look to make
sure it's not you guys I mean how bad could it be I have to
deal with deadlock melee mind game that's true how bad could
apex be it's not that bad it's agreeable you're like
wreaking desperation she's scared me She sounds like she's
trying to be like a demon.
She's not.
She's not like a realtor.
I got you guys like free breakfast at this meeting and I'm
trying to sell you time shoes right now.
I grabbed donuts.
We guys want some free donuts and some free vouchers.
How are the rest of the players going to feel about you,
Reza guys?
Well, they won't.
I'm not Rezaing you guys.
I'm just leaving you guys.
you're gonna leave you're gonna you're gonna hire us onto
this tournament we're not gonna make any money or win any
games we're gonna have bond we're gonna have time we're
gonna spend time together as as a group of friends having
the time of our lives on different memories and can the
other teams also kill us hey dokey hey dokey who's on your
who's on your team dokey i can't stop i don't know yet i
don't oh are you are you sure it could be us it could be us
pros and pros there could only be three people on a team i'm
gonna pick two of you guys oh big drama i can only pick two
of you
and mint have already agreed to make time you know it's
really on that wait wait wait wait wait yeah yeah yeah hold
on which two should i pick guys should we all and that is
why we should all be in this tournament together as a team
but we're not a team you know like when you get a facebook
message from someone and they're like hey hey guys how have
you been it's so nice to talk to you again and then they
like come up with some utter bullshit.
It's an MLM.
Yeah.
We're doing MLMs by Doki right now.
Yeah, truly.
But if you about to ask me to test your Minecraft game.
Here's my Minecraft mod deck, by the way.
Can you click on the link and download it for me real quick?
Guys, I swear to God, it's so fun.
Stop saying that.
It's scaring me more.
So, guys, gonna mark you guys down as a yes is that what
we're as a strong baby no no no no guys guys guys definitely
no no i thought you said you were gonna i thought you said
you were down early and how i would rather stick my nose
into the toilet than play this like scam that you're selling
me right now not a scam i swear to god i swear to y'all i
swear to god it's not scam and everybody's gonna have a
great time and I guys you need to work better on your sales
it's I guys it's just I've been trying I've been planned
I've had like four three three days to plan this guys wait I
have a question I have a question Doki yes if theoretically
I joined your tournament and then suffered a catastrophic
inability to use my keyboard and sandbagged out early would
this well you can't be you can't stand back early because
each game is its own thing oh yeah so you would leave us you
would leave us no no no i'll i'll say you'd sabotage you
that's different just like a family we're so we're so lovely
you get free street okay yeah yeah yeah wait there's free
you get free skins I don't play but but but it's free but
it's free it's just like that time you know when we did the
Marvel rivals tournament and won and I got all that currency
for skins and then dead stopped playing the game from that
moment on yeah but you still you got it though yeah it's
just sitting there it's just sitting there yeah yeah but you
still you still got it it's like it's like the image of you
know you you earned it you know this one's like a reward
yeah yeah it's like a pride of accomplishing like you guys
could if you guys live to fourth place you can get money and
out of 10 out of 10 teams out of 10 teams out of 10 teams
like and it's like hide and seek i thought you said 10
players 10 teams of three 10 teams of Oh my god.
That's at least 30 people.
But in a regular Apex match, it would have been 20 teams.
So it's cut in half.
So it's really very reasonable.
Like you need a great market rate.
There's only more people in more games you have to play.
50% chance.
There's a 50% chance you can place at least fourth place.
Like.
Okay, again, as a team or like as an individual, what's the
as a team as a team together.
Okay, okay.
I still think I would not want to do that.
I don't want to do it.
I don't even know what the map looks like.
I don't even know how to like play the game.
I'd be I'd be playing in grass.
I know other people would be hiding in the best places and
we'd find little bushes.
What was the what was the map?
It's like world's edge and everyone drops on the edge.
I think you already know like 90% more than the other you
already know 90% more than the other two as we share in life
and the other two us you talking about us I can name one
apex map so a huge advantage huge you can name a map and a
game yeah the world I don't know I know an apex character
It's high time.
It's high noon.
You know what?
It sounds like you kind of like merged Cassidy and Namur or
something.
And Namur's don't let's know.
It's high tide.
And he just like floods the arena or something.
Well, he does say it's high tide when Cassidy has his beach
skin on.
So I think
I only played over which one and a very small amount of two.
That's the truth.
So guys, you guys want me to mark you guys down as a yes
son.
You were so convincing.
I honestly think it depends on whether or not I feel better
because I am very mush right now.
You're sick right now from Bexford.
I am so bad.
Were you patient zero?
You're bullying us.
No, but she's weaker, so I decided to lead to gaslight.
Oh, one person?
I don't know.
But like, I swear half of Vexpo is sick.
That's crazy.
There's some people who are like, yo, my nose is bleeding.
Is this normal?
And it's like, no, that's just your brain hemorrhaging.
Don't worry about it.
Oh my God.
I don't know what's going on with them.
My nose is fine.
I think my brain matters safe.
But oh my God.
That's crazy.
I just keep coughing and sneezing and sniffling as well.
pretty bad that's pretty bad you're gonna turn into like a
fungus it's bad enough i was i was playing deadlock doki and
yeah i was taking the double sinners and i failed basic math
and was like yeah i can do one last hit to finish this
sinner off did one last hit fucking die dropped a 1k bag my
team ran into the sinners because they thought i'd gotten
jumped by the enemy team and they were like did you die to
the sinner and i was like no yes They were only just like
standing in the entranceway staring at me as I did my walk
of shame to get my bag.
Oh, that's our REM.
That's...
I wasn't even REM, I was fucking Mina.
That's our Mina.
Oh my god.
I got my hazmat suit on.
That's why we're in the back.
Yeah, thank god we're in the back rooms, guys.
Oh shit, sorry, I just realized.
So guys, for those who don't know...
don't oh yeah for those who don't know on friday on friday
i'll be hosting an apex tournament where apex legend street
fighter collab everybody and you're gonna see me and the
sloppy sisters there on friday yeah you know friday is also
uh the last invite the sloppy sisters you to draw this
collab isn't it right i would send a video message saying
good luck everybody all right okay i'll take that i'll take
i'll take a video can we just can we just like be mascots
and send moral support oh my god wait do you like that one
like cowboy video where you're like in the sky just being
like good luck dokey like green screen yeah yeah put us in
put us in okay i'll take those where they do the canon
honestly yeah i'll unless you would that would work better
for me unless anyone wants to be on my team you know i have
and wants to volunteer themselves to be part of my team.
And, and, you know, you know, have fun.
I do enjoy, I do enjoy fun.
Yeah, it's gonna, it's gonna be really fun.
I like how Mint is so quiet right now.
It's like, like, don't pick me, teacher.
Don't pick me.
It might be like, I'm doing the tutorial.
Oh yeah, wait, there's a tutorial.
Mint's like her sights based on movement and she's just not
engaging at all oh my gosh i didn't know there were bananas
in this game well it's the back room doesn't really happen
change the subject we're playing back rooms today yippee
yeah oh yeah also by the way guys wait did i download the
right game wait what is this one it's back but uh pre-orders
for the sloppy sisters gina collab oh yeah that's what we're
here this week guys this week this week it's like 25th or
was it 20th 25th or 27th 25th on the day of my apex legend
street fighter unrelated unrelated oh my god related but
it's on the killing me in real time it's on the same day
guys unrelated let me put the image up but i have a pin in
my chat for those who want to check it out guys in pre-order
join i realized like after the stream was over when we
announced it it was seemed like we were people to
fraternities or sororities did you get yeah i thought that
was the point no i thought i was like originally i was just
like oh yeah sloppy university but i was like wait it's like
joining a fraternity yeah i thought it was true i thought
everyone kind of has like their own little like aesthetic to
to yeah yeah i would definitely be like to people do people
do people in like real real real life in american like
colleges actually do those like crazy yes basically like
torture entry exams yeah that's that's crazy there's like
yeah there's like i went to university of course it was like
an art university but nothing like that happened to me
sometimes they do chance in the sewers i the sewers where
the fuck is your university i'm not gonna talk to myself
the year I graduated I know like for my for my university um
they did hazing where it was it was like you know it's in
Canada and it's snowing and then apparently the guys uh the
guys are doing a hazing for their fraternity and they were
all running like streaking naked in the snow oh yeah yeah
it's just that sounds more like a good time than torture it
was okay wait you're American so I don't know how convert it
to, oh wait, to like freedom units, but it was like below.
Oh, I know Celsius.
Mint, do you know Celsius?
I know Celsius.
Oh.
I don't sound, if that does not sound very convincing.
What do you mean, it's true.
All right, what's room temperature in Celsius, Mint?
Oh, Google it.
What's room temperature in Fahrenheit?
Yeah, but that doesn't matter because only Americans use
freedom units.
What do you mean it doesn't matter?
I don't know.
Actually, I don't know what room temperature is normally.
Normally Celsius is abnormal, huh?
No, in general.
What's 20 degrees Celsius to Fahrenheit?
That's like...
Like 70...
eight I know that's not bad wait you know the conversion
it's it's seven you don't even know why would I know it's
not my I hear your keyboard I hear it yeah because I'm
fact-checking her I need a fair night I'm gonna fact-check
her it's actually 68 I'm not googling the intro I was 10
degrees I was so close but Fahrenheit 10 degrees is a lot so
Fahrenheit 10 degrees.
That's really cold.
Yeah.
I know what that one is.
Trying to find the picture of the Gina collab, the show on
stream right now.
Give me a sec, guys.
You should get the one where it was like the video playing,
but it was actually the fucking Spider-Man comic panel.
That one was good, though.
I'm sorry.
They're like, tear tactile not included, Spider-Man not
included.
I've been showing off the detail shots.
I'm trying to download.
They're so pretty.
Oh, I should download.
Yeah, I'm trying to download.
Where are they?
Send them in the Discord, please.
What do you mean, where are they?
I only have mine.
That's Steiner for yours.
That guy doesn't do anything.
Leaks, leaks, leaks.
Google Docs coming out.
Here's the details of the...
Oh, I already had it saved.
Here's the details.
I'm going to go use the bathroom.
I need to also get more like a little bit of a spear bank.
Okay, I'm trying.
I saved my picture.
Alright guys, here's what they look like for my collection.
Here's what they look like for my collection.
collection wait slash collection slash sloppy my collection
here's my collection now here's my collection mine look at
that beautiful beautiful look at these colors beautiful you
know what i've heard many people say that i have the most
swag so i'm just you know i'm not i'm just fact stating what
was already stated not my own opinion but i have heard
rumors about your swag But, you know, the swag produced on,
if you were to join my fraternity, you know, I don't know
much about hazing, but I have heard stories.
I think we'll probably tie you to a tree overnight.
We go into sewers and we chant.
It's specifically in the sewers.
No, I remember.
There were stories at my campus that people would walk by
the sewers and hear chanting.
Are you sure his fraternity and not a fucking cult?
Oh, I don't know.
I mean, why would they do it at school then?
That's weird.
I don't know.
It could be the Ninja Turtles.
You had Ninja Turtles.
Yeah, the Ninja Turtles.
They're going to school too, man.
Yeah, they have to go, they have to get higher education
too.
You think they're just gonna lay around and not look out for
their careers after being ninjas?
Yeah, being ninjas forever, guys.
You gotta look at their, you gotta look into their futures.
You gotta have a 401k.
forever.
Because there's no 401k being a ninja.
What's never guaranteed?
What is the retirement fund gonna look like?
Are they investing in anything for their future?
Are they?
Wow.
I think nerd turtles.
How long do they realistically actually they live a long
time.
They live a long time.
Yeah, what happens?
That means they just have a longer time to be ninjas.
Yeah, exactly.
Let them be ninjas for longer.
It's like having a career injury.
They can't, it's like if someone does basketball and they
they fucked up their their knee or some shit they can't go
back to basketball and then they're fucked well maybe they
make money they live in New York they're probably really
well off they live in the sewer stuffy that means they have
no money they have to see they get to save everything yeah
maybe they have this is why they were in the college now
what's their income from from from being a ninja huh where
do they I don't know.
I thought they get free food.
Pizza.
Yeah, they get free.
That's all they need.
Pizza and the sewers.
They have free food.
What if they want to settle down?
Look for a family?
Look for a wife or husband?
I don't think turtles even have wives.
Oh!
I don't think they need them.
I don't know.
I think they reproduce like a second.
sexually or something.
Wait, okay, wait, no, actually never mind.
I didn't.
Wait, what were you gonna do?
Did I miss anything?
I missed the video of the turtle.
Don't you was about to show us how turtles have sex.
I think so.
I think actually that's what she was about to show us.
It was a famous, it's a famous turtle video.
Okay, not famous, but it's a funny, it's a funny TikTok meme
of a turtle just.
a funny tiktok meme of a turtle just having a good time just
having a good time having a good time no it's not famous how
did you find this it showed up on my twitter that's how I
get most of my news sources and you're saying because he's
having a good time he doesn't reproduce asexually yes why
would yes Yes, that's what it means.
It's literally funny turtle vine.
I literally...
Am I going to watch this?
Did you link it?
Yes, I'm going to link it.
You're going to link it to me?
I'm going to link it in the collabs channel.
It's not really a tutorial.
It's just a little area.
So like Mimi and Mattaya would see the video if they ever
look up the server for educational purposes.
Glad you made this obtainable for everyone.
I don't want anybody to miss out on this free information.
Yeah, funny turtle vine panting.
3.6 million views.
I'm scared to watch this.
I don't understand what's happening in this video.
There's nothing happening.
You're clearly not.
Don't have volume on.
I mean, he's panting, but there's not even like, you know,
else.
You can't even see if there's other turtles.
There's a turtle right below him.
You see the shell.
It's going to easily be a rock.
I'm not watching the video.
It's safe for work.
It's not.
How is this not safe for work?
I linked it in my chat.
You want that?
You linked it in your chat?
How many of these views are yours, don't you?
It's like, it's like four views.
That's a lot.
Was it the last hour or what?
Plus one was with you guys.
I didn't watch it.
I didn't click it.
No, but I clicked it just because I was trying to find the
video for you guys.
And then you watched it again.
Yeah, because I wanted to make sure it was the right video.
And you remember every aspect of it.
funny video yes i will remember if the video was funny i
would god do you have any idea how hard it is to find a
video or sorry find a game on the twitch directory just by
typing back rooms yeah there's a lot of back rooms there's
something we could have cleanup crew yeah we're the cleanup
crew yeah we're here at post back rooms wait should we make
a lobby we should i just i just realized it's been 30
minutes and we're still not in the back rooms No.
Alright.
I haven't seen the movie, so I'm not going to get any
awesome lessons.
Is it sound okay?
No.
I don't think it's related as much.
I've seen the movie.
I haven't seen it.
I saw the movie after all the memes, so it ruined it for me
because every conversation was just like, ha ha, just like
in the Roblox game.
Ha ha.
In the Roblox game.
What?
Oh, yeah.
I made a Roblox game.
Someone made a fucking Roblox backrooms game where you play
like, a like you play clarks everyone's a clark and you oh
yeah that's the that's the main guy clark is the main
character from bedrooms and he's like he's very quotable
because he says things like i'm a fucking architect and over
and over again and he like he he does that and then there's
like captain clark which is like the the the master yes yes
yeah i saw that yeah as the pirate and so other like there's
other players are captain clerks and they have to chase the
clarks and then it's just like millions of them running
around go going like I'm an architect it's just a wave of
water it just ruined the movie for me it's like a serious is
that what happens in the movie yeah you know that's the
specifics I mean he says the lines in the movie I don't
think he gets chased around by roblox players I mean he gets
chased by actually he doesn't really get chased by the
pirate but there's a pirate in it There's a pirate in the
movie.
Oh.
It's pretty good.
I'm going to stay in character.
Yeah, yeah.
Stay in character.
I'm doing the tutorial now too.
Oh, this is like Power Watch simulator.
Yeah, I think you could just make the lobby.
Yeah, just make the lobby.
Make the lobby.
Okay, who's making the lobby?
Come on, bird.
Make the lobby.
Doki.
Doki, you're clearly making the lobby.
We talked about this.
All right, give me a sec.
I'm going to do the tutorial real quick.
That is done.
I've been like I've been cleaning off the arrows on the
walls I'm like I'm so done with talking about turtle sex I
was just like five minutes five minutes of turtle sex is a
long conversation too long what do you mean what do you mean
wait there are bananas yeah the nozzles bigger I feel like i
actually i don't think you can oh there's like if you scroll
wheel you can change the type of nozzle yeah there's like a
huge one yeah all right let's see how do i how do i make
multiplayer uh wait how do i invite you guys
i'm i'll figure this out guys i'm getting rid of the
tutorial i'm i'm pressure washing it off i'm done with this
okay uh Have you been enjoying Crime Scene Cleaner a minute?
Oh yeah!
Have you played it?
It's one of my favorite games ever.
Kowalski's so funny.
It's so good!
It's so good.
It's beautiful.
I love it so much.
I was so glad when they came out with like the second part
and everything.
I just like how he wanders into a room and someone's been
like deep fried by like a...
He's basically like, you know the CSI memes where it's like,
looks like she.
I don't know.
And then he just makes some horrible fucking fun.
looks like she we look i don't know i was trying to give a
pun but my brain is mush yeah it looks like no he's not
great wasn't the only thing for i got the i got the lobby
code guys oh there's a code yeah yeah you gotta do the uh
you gotta join from back in the lobby area or press escape
and then do most press multiplayer and then do join code it
like shows the thing off does it show the I don't know.
Okay, it does show the code.
Join lobby by code.
Okay.
But yeah, it's basically, I just think Kowalski is really
funny because of like the really weird deadpan, like blind
delivery and stuff.
It's so good.
I had a good time.
Yeah, because it's a story game too, right?
You live.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, your name is Lawson.
Your name is Gabriel.
Oh, cool.
What's happening?
Wait, what are you guys in?
Oh, yeah.
Nikita.
I'm Nikita.
Wait, how do you guys see them?
Oh, you have name tags.
say gabriel yeah yeah wait is there no invoice game like no
i don't know i don't think we need invoice sure what's my
employee benefit all right let's go start the mission i can
go all the way to the other side i noticed we couldn't like
change our name or our suit color it was like no i don't
think so yeah we have to lock in no i couldn't get girl all
right oh oh i'm going all right guys it's time to clean the
back what the heck is all of this Hello, cleaner.
I can go in here.
No, you can't.
You're too short.
I just jumped.
No, you can.
You're too short.
I literally see you missing.
I'm not listening to this man at all.
Dang.
Where's the garbage at?
I'm pretty sure everything is.
Useless shit pile.
Oh, there's garbage here.
Oh, clean is.
Where's the garbage can that we throw things in?
Useless it pile.
Use it.
I like the body physics and crime scene cleaner.
I like trying to toss Who's redacted?
Who are you?
Me.
What?
Who's redacted?
We're redacted now I guess because we're in the back rooms.
Oh that's true because we can't like let people know who we
are.
Is that a rule in the back room?
Is that a rule in the back?
Because we're like secret undercover.
It's like NDA.
We all signed an NDA to clean the back rooms.
I didn't sign nothing.
But we ran the back rooms together so we totally already saw
her yeah yeah but we don't want we don't want people other
people in the back oh yeah other people you don't want the
bad guys to know what your name is yeah yeah the rat like
you guys know the back rooms lore right like how you
honestly i never did much with back rooms i like it's just p
better it's just basically like uh what was Are we going to
actually get a tag to the back rooms?
Anybody can get into the back rooms because it's like a
pocket dimension, basically.
So you can fall into the back rooms.
Yeah, you went through it through the Clark's furniture
store.
Yeah.
So there's like different entrances to the back rooms.
So like we could bump into some random dude from like, I
don't know, from the UK that hopped in from the back rooms.
That sounds awesome.
Nobody lives in the UK.
It'll be stupid.
The best way to travel.
I just found out Bob the Builder is British guys.
Wait, Bob the Builder is British.
That's what I was saying!
It's because America redubbed the show to make him sound
American.
You think redubbed Bob the Builder?
Bob the Builder was different the whole time.
That was like my favorite show ever.
I'm a long-running community joke.
My first ever crush was...
Oh.
Oh Oh my god oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh, oh, okay Attack it clean it clean it clean it There's
like rain mechanics What is this?
Okay, we got it?
I don't know who died!
What is that?
It's one of them who died!
Wait, clean it!
Clean it, clean it!
Okay, we cleaned it!
Oh, you cleaned my soul!
I cleaned your soul.
We got this?
You have been cleansed.
Very good.
I think that was it.
Oh, okay.
Yay!
Anyway, so Bob the Builder was actually originally a British
TV show.
And then in America, we re-dubbed it.
for some reason.
What?
They learn so much though.
They can't expose them to British accents.
They'll be terrified.
What happened to Peppa Pig?
All the children.
They knew that the Peppa Pig would happen, you know, because
now the children speak with British accents.
That's true!
And they didn't want to be with Bob.
They didn't want to be, yeah, back then they didn't want the
kids to grow up to be British.
Is that like a confirmed phenomenon?
Is like the Peppa Pig like accent development?
Yeah, because babies.
bluey too over this same with bluey yeah bluey makes people
australia yeah bluey is it really yeah yeah it's your
australian don't watch it bluey makes evil australian what
the heck so they're like mom has too many like cozy roads
you know that's how you know it should have never been
american is there's too many like one lane little like farm
rooms wait can't believe it i wonder way like open items i
picked a bunch up and now i don't know okay oh you just
throw them you threw the trash i was trying to i was trying
to do really good i was trying to make it is this way oh
it's supposed to go in here yeah i was trying to make it all
explode when you just take it you know I wonder what other
shows they redubbed in american just because they just
didn't like yaks i feel like there was a lot more french
canadian stuff than i ever knew possible i mean yeah totally
spies originally french clear you changed the name of a book
series i read as a child because they thought i guess they
thought that americans would struggle what was it what was
it well there's two there's one where like the philosopher
stone became sorcerer stone and then the other one was like
they changed they changed it to compass instead of Northern
light.
It's okay.
See, I'm cleaning.
I'm cleaning.
Cleanse the room.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh.
Is everybody okay?
Spray our souls.
Clean my bowls.
Okay.
We'll get the soul.
Where are you guys?
I'm cleaning my bowls.
Clean our souls.
I'm cleaning.
I'm cleaning your soul.
You want me to cleanse.
I'm cleaning.
Watch out.
Oh.
Guys, guys, guys.
Okay, we got it.
My soul needs to be clean.
Okay, cleaning your soul.
All right.
All right, let's get this one.
Ooh, watch out.
Oh, shit, it's over here.
Yeah, it's up here.
I feel like you don't want to get clean.
Oh my God!
Ow!
Cleaning, cleaning, clean, clean.
There you go.
All right, oh my God.
You guys got blood everywhere.
Come on.
You didn't revive and like your hips are, your hips are
thrusting.
Why are your hips thrusting in death?
Oh my God.
What are they doing?
I didn't get my balls washed enough.
I want your balls.
My dog is not happy about it.
Yeah, yeah.
He's just like, ball?
Ball?
Where are ball?
My name changed.
It says my new name is live.
Oh, I'm Eduardo Gabriel.
Wait, how do you know your name?
Because when you die, a new guy takes over.
And it says your name is now.
Yeah, your name is now.
It like flashed in the corner for a second.
I have been reborn.
I gotta feed my dog.
Give me a sec, guys.
I'm gonna take my five minute break.
Smoke break.
I hope you die.
Oh!
Yay!
Wait, why did we only get a silver?
We were slow.
Because people died.
Oh, I think we're slow.
Unlocked blue!
Oh, we got blue!
Will you be...
All right, guys.
I gotta be moved to the blue.
I'm a purist.
I want to be yellow.
Yellow?
Oh, it could be like canonical.
That's like the back room's color.
Okay, okay.
True.
Zero deaths, baby.
Zero deaths.
Let's go.
Nice, nice.
Loki went for her smoke break and she left me with her dog.
Or Libra, was that your dog?
My dog, no.
My dog's quiet.
He's a good boy right now.
Whose dog is this?
Am I crazy?
Do you guys hear it?
It's mine, it's mine.
That's actually just me in the corner.
Yeah, sorry.
Oh, she's the host.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, well, why is she, why is she beer bags?
I'm gonna take this opportunity to like tinkle really quick.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Looky-duck.
How are you feeling, Limeo?
I'm so stiffly.
I'm back.
Oh, no.
Welcome back.
Oh, I guess we returned to that.
Oh, Snuffy went to go tinkle.
All right.
Yeah, Snuffy went to his bathroom.
I guess we just...
Oh, you guys can change suit colors if you want it.
Well, let me raise my game volume a little.
He was really quiet in the actual back rooms, but in here
he's quite loud.
I don't know.
Yeah, I know, right?
I can't ignore him.
I love you.
I mean, he's our boss, though.
skills from information wants to be blue i think i'm waiting
for a green i think that informs me that usage of the
terminal increases a cleaner's field efficiency and limb
retention metrics by statistically significant margin yeah
yeah yeah wait your name is vagrant i'm vague you're fraya
now fraya oh my god what happened to our old selves they got
fired they died they got lost in the names um kate it's a
international facility olden what's my new name you're old
old gov oh oh god oh wait no oh wait it is old gov oh you're
right oh wait what's what's my yours kate kate kate you're
just kate we're like i like how your name's in a heart i
know right
here Kate yeah Kate from HR try and want it why are you
moving dick first I mean like the way the way that you walk
oh don't don't do it slowly yeah you're just you're just
calm down calm down first man wait what do you what does
this look like you move here watch watch this is you making
my way downtown well I'm I can't hear snuffy can you guys oh
she's not back yet she's not back yet she went to pee yeah
she's still peeing oh you're right the very she's doing this
right now a kersian research terminal oh I'm back welcome
back welcome back oh goff yeah that's your new name oh goff
what happened to Lila we did she got lost in the back rooms
oh my god She never came back.
Change your color.
Go become blue.
Go be blue.
How do I do it?
Did you guys listen to them talking about how to upgrade
your nozzles and stuff?
No.
Did you?
It's that terminal here.
Over here.
You upgrade your nozzles.
Am I blue?
Yes.
Oh, I spent it all on nozzle.
I should not have spent it on nozzle, guys.
I should not have spent it.
That was good.
Clean Foster.
I don't think it's shared money, is it?
it doesn't no it's not shared you can spend your own yeah
this is the first time in any game that i feel like we've
actually gotten points to do something i know okay this game
this game is weirdly functional oh i did like that when i
launched it it was like would you like lumen ray tracing i
was like jesus christ i know right you understand what that
meant man don't
what that meant, Mint.
Don't predict.
No, no.
All right, what's lumen ray tracing, Mint?
No, no, I didn't understand.
This game runs really bad.
It's breaking for me all the time.
If you, Mint, if you go to settings, uh, and then go to
graphics, turn, turn the global illumination quality,
reflections quality, and shadow quality down.
Oh, I did already.
Yeah, I did.
It's not on lumen high.
Oh, okay.
It just runs bad.
Wait, what's your specs, Mint?
What's your spec?
Mine's fine.
What specs do you have?
It keeps screen tearing for me.
Oh, turn V-Sync on.
I don't think there was one, was there?
I know.
Mine's one in gray.
It's in video.
Oh, in video.
Yeah, you can turn V-Sync on there.
Oh, I didn't check there.
Really, that would be the first thing you check.
Oh, yay.
No, I went under graphics.
Oh, yeah, it's true.
It's like, it's not in graphics.
it in video it actually worked though wait i it was on ultra
i forgot i got it on title it's fine it worked anyway it
worked anyway though yeah all right let's go to i'm going to
the second area i wonder about if there's a faster way to do
this cool all right analysis rest assured that attacks
suffered by f corp workers during the last mission are being
taken seriously as your safety is our utmost concern we have
dispatched group scientists to investigate while we're still
waiting their initial findings redacted has issued a new
cleanup request to attach coordinates all right whoa it's
true since crime scene cleaner i can't actually clean
without knowing the backstory first so this is important to
me yeah okay okay all right i feel like the eyes might send
stuff on the floor i'm a little worried i think things just
spawn in it doesn't really matter if they Cleaning,
cleaning, cleaning, cleaning.
Do you want a guy job?
Are the same people as the other cleaning?
No, I don't think so.
I think you just took the idea and then be like, what if
it's in the back rooms?
Because like back rooms is like, nobody can copyright the
back.
But it's also like open source.
Is that the right word?
Or the trash candle?
Creative Commons, I think.
Hey, hey!
I know!
No, no, no, no, no.
I feel like there's gonna be something to do with the eyes.
But what do we know is considered junk though?
What if someone just wants to- I just started taking
everything.
Yeah, everything is junk.
Everything is junk.
A public domain, that's why I'm- Yeah, it's a public domain.
Public domain, there you go.
Yeah, it's like- Oh, yeah, yeah.
What's public domain?
The back rooms.
Yeah, because it's what's made on the internet.
Internet lore.
Yeah, it was from a public forum, so technically it's like
by anonymous person.
and people are you a public domain no you are you in the
internet i hope not stuffy but i was born on the internet
i'm like a public domain yeah but you're gonna go oh but you
own the copyright of yourself because it's like circles are
like some jungy ito shit oh that's true because the back
rooms nobody owns the back rooms i would have taken credit
for that i don't know who like missed out I would have said
sometimes that's my invention I did that I know like what's
the movie company behind the back rooms John movie company
John movie because I know they tried to trademark the back
rooms in some way oh they tried to trademark the wallpaper
of the back rooms the wall all paper yeah yeah yeah that's
kind of a key I mean I guess if you think about it it's a
pretty market that happens visual style of it so I get it
yeah yeah yeah there's a oh oh oh oh it's the same thing oh
the sigils clean the sigils oh shit I got one I got one I
got one
Don't die!
Oh my god!
There's like these aura.
Wash us!
Wash us, please!
Guys, we need to wash!
Oh my god!
Where are you?
We're down here in the corner!
Here, I'll keep going up here.
I'll keep getting this guy.
Thank you.
We need to get washed.
I'm washing you.
You're so dirty.
Oh, I got it.
I'm a clean boy now.
It's really hard to see where the explosions are going to
be.
Where's the...
Oh, there's the last one.
I didn't even see that.
You mean that the one right in front of us?
I'm a clean boy now!
I didn't see the one on the floor.
I wish I had like soap.
but i found out about the wallpaper thing because like
apparently some guy actually owned the actual wallpaper of
the from the back rooms like not not because they went to
the back rooms but it was like just some some old wallpaper
by the back rooms somebody said that the back no somebody in
my chat said they were in wisconsin is that back room is
there like real back rooms i fully believe oh yeah it's
apparently a mall it was like or an office building or
something you mean the place that they actually took the
original picture i was like i thought you really clarified
yeah so by the way the back room is located in wisconsin i
thought maybe it was really it just was like not the lore
but it was like you know because the liminal photo of the
back rooms had to have been taken somewhere yeah yeah it was
it was pre-ai yeah which is very scary now with how it's
like how everyone knows where the amazing amazing digital
circus was yes I've been.
Wait, what?
You've been to the sexual circus?
You were awesome.
Don't forget the guns.
Those also count when you die.
You have to clean them up.
Oh, shit.
You guys, yeah, you guys make a mess.
You squirt your blood everywhere.
Yeah.
You really do make a big old mess.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for me.
I'm sorry for my body as has.
You should be sorry for not cleaning up after yourself.
After your nasty bodily flu is on the floor.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like I can't control my body.
Mint, do you ever try trickshotting bodies into the car in
real life?
I do it.
Yeah, it's so funny.
You guys be like over the corner, off the rim, and into the
basket.
Yeah, I did a sick shot literally yesterday.
And you 360?
Wait, yeah, now you can lift it up and, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Where is it?
Okay.
What is in front of me?
I got the one in front.
That's a lot of explosions.
We should be fine.
Oh, bump, bump, bump.
I should be fine.
There's a giant pillar, spiky pillar here.
Got one.
I got one, too.
Oh, on me?
Okay.
On me?
He's one.
He's one shot.
One shot?
So you're practicing for Epex already, guys.
Shield cracked, shield cracked.
You're practicing for Friday.
Yeah, we're practicing for Friday, guys.
Shields cracked.
I'm pushing.
I'm reloading.
Cover me.
Cover me, guys.
That's the last thing.
Oh, I got knocked.
I got knocked.
Oh, yeah, good.
Yippee.
We're so good at this game.
Oh, my gosh.
It's the moment we started calming.
Oh, great.
Green!
Lival.
Yay.
Guys, when we started calming, guys.
Oh, my.
I think we got Friday.
I think Friday was going to go so well.
for all of us.
Yeah, you guys sound excited.
Good luck.
Yeah, including you, Snuffy.
No, I don't even know anything.
You guys are all making references.
I don't even understand.
Yeah, nice gun.
I'm shooting.
Like, that's all I can say.
I don't know.
I'm crying.
I'm shooting.
I'm sitting everywhere.
I'm just scared.
I'm in the corner right now.
I hear a lot of gunshots.
What do I do I won't even know which one my own teammates
are like it'll be so bad.
I don't know your own teammate not intentionally Luckily,
there's no friendly five All right, are you guys ready for
oh the next reward is a red suit color guys.
Oh, we're gonna get promoted Wow Are you guys ready for the
next mission?
Yeah, all right.
Oh, I forgot to read the lore.
I guess we'll never know what happened.
I don't know how to I actually haven't been listening to you
to be fair I'm used to it just in case people didn't notice
in the tutorial you can hold right or you can press right
click so you don't have to hold this oh I forgot to upgrade
my god oh you can hold it yeah right you can press right
click instead of left click and it will okay spray it hasn't
been an incident here what are you talking can I ask you
guys a personal question yeah uh-huh how do you wash your
feet in the shower like do you guys have like one of those
little brushes or like do you do you just scrub it like
normally like any body part what do you mean by brushes like
what what brush are you talking about to brush you can get a
brush for like abrasions so because like some people get
like hard toe on the bottom of their feet stuffy what the
fuck is wrong with your toes no no no it's not like a no no
those are like pumice stones for like you know i don't know
i just used the lufa thing that like like the shower poof
thing okay i hear like those those aren't actually good for
your body in general yeah i haven't like died yet so like
it's like i'm not healthy for your yet i mean it's just not
healthy for your skin type deal to have a i mean if you're
going crazy with it probably not but you know i'm just i'm
not like breaking it across my skin till i bleed I found a
body.
I'm a constant.
Oh, wait, wait.
I want to see the body.
Whoa.
That's what happened.
He's like wiggling like he's in low gravity or something.
It's the back room.
What's his name?
Let's look at his name.
Sean.
Remember him.
All right, Sean.
We'll remember you, Sean.
I'm going to put you in the trash now by Sean.
Oh, my God.
It's like Sean never existed.
Don't worry, Sean.
He didn't.
Leave no trace.
He's going to come back.
Oh, what's that?
It's Sean.
I told you.
It's the spirit of Sean.
Oh, my God.
What?
We got send him.
It sounds like Counter Strike.
We're playing Counter Strike.
It sounds like the trainer.
We're aim training.
Did you know?
What is he doing?
Is he like pooping out something?
What's going on?
He's throwing bananas at us.
Oh, maybe don't go close to him.
Oh, maybe you're right.
Oh.
Oh, well, Sean, why did you make a mess, Sean?
Little snacks.
Yeah, but like a prankster.
He's so funny.
I ran away.
I'm glad he's dead.
But yeah, he was pretty annoying guys, you know, like, you
know how I swear he was eating like from our and from the
fridge from the community fridge Those were my community
fridge.
I think it was Sean, you know, I thought it was the
community fridge if it's not for the community Yeah, but
then my my I had my yeah, I wrote my name on a sticky note I
thought that just meant that you left it for me because
you're so nice am i supposed to throw these away no i throw
everything away oh oh damn it john i was in the middle of
that john oh more and more stop trying to commute with sean
the evil sigils oh my god why do they just want to be
friends whoa whoa i died hello oh i'm okay i'm washing oh oh
this is bad
Oh, oh, explosives.
I'm dead behind a table.
Ooh, that was close.
I'm washing, I'm washing.
All right, I'll go wash, too.
Thank you.
Oh, God, I felt like explosions.
All right, I would like you to stop bleeding as much,
though.
It is sort of ruining the vibe.
Where else are they?
I think maybe, oh, it's back on my way, it's back here.
Oh, there's one over here, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, it's all the way back here?
Yeah, in the back rooms.
be it no i think it just i think it's a set period or you
kill emolia yeah so this feels very much like it's it's
christmas aesthetic i feel like it's very green red it's so
green now oh wait you're right to adjust why is it green oh
um maybe they maybe the back rooms really were copywritten
no but the last the last room the last room was yellow this
one is really green i guess they You know, they're trying to
rebrand, you know to to it was getting dirtier.
That's why we're cleaning it.
It must be moldy I assume like a Christmas cleaning great
game.
You should do viscera cleanup details Oh, no, we did do it.
Min and I played it before you played that one.
Yeah, remember it's the one with the gore Yeah, and like you
know like the gnome body parts if like, you know, you opened
a cupboard It would they would fall out and then get blood
everywhere.
I think we did we didn't do the yeah Yeah, yeah, that was
terrible.
I did not like that game Well, it's because it was like
every single, we had to clean every single speck and we're
like, where the fuck is the last one?
Like, if you knocked over the bucket or something, it would
like, oh yeah, and the blood again.
Yeah, I hated, hated.
You had a good time, man.
You had, oh, God.
Oh, you were only 100% with that.
It's literally your job, man.
Oh, ew.
Yeah, I'm really good at crime scene cleaner.
What was that?
Oh, my God, it's the spirit of Sean again.
I'm Sean again!
Sean!
Sean is giving us banners from the heavens!
It's like a snack break.
What more is this in the back rooms?
Like, are these angry, restless spirits that reside inside
the hallways?
I don't understand.
It's just Sean.
You just want to run into that and see if it warps you into
something stupid.
Oh yeah.
I think it would definitely just blow you up.
It also pooped a book out, or did somebody throw a book out?
Sean wants you to read, Snuffy.
Oh my God!
yeah read more all right what's what's the last thing you
read that wasn't a fan fiction uh the warrior cats oh wait
have you actually kept up to date with a warrior cat shit
i've been reading it on stream to my viewers
what book are you guys we got two stars in that one we're on
the second book it's good we're ready for the game i hope
you guys are gonna play Oh, I'm playing a game.
Yeah, they're coming out of the Warrior Cats game.
Yeah, it looks like a freaking Roblox game.
It's like, uh, that's, I won't, no, I, I agree.
It's like an RP, it's gonna be an RPG.
Yeah.
Hi, okay.
Yeah, you get to be a cat.
I used to go to, I used to roleplay Warrior Cats and
Neopets.
Oh, my, stop.
I could marry you.
Yeah, um, my Warrior Cat name was, uh, Wild Pelt.
Uh, Wild Pelt.
I got it from I got it generate no, you know like okay in
the warrior cats website you can generate website generate
yeah, yeah, yeah the name generator.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and I got it from warrior Yeah, it's so
pure from a sick and twisted bitch like you Wow God damn
Who is that man?
You were so cute and innocent at some point You're so messed
up and now you play apex messed up what I'm the norm I'm the
normals oh there's like seminars and cosmetics you can buy
too oh yeah I want to play solo though so some of them are
just like not even no some of them are relevant to yeah wait
this is cute there's a yellow face plate plate color and a
Sakura suit color I can be fully yellow yeah where is fully
yellow i'm gonna be fully yellow but change the logo color
oh very expensive though wait that does not look good as
good i want to see which one is it does not look as good as
i thought it was gonna look right did you buy it yeah it
looks like you like you like sneezed all over your eyes
Guys, I don't have any more sick days, guys.
I think it comes away.
I'm just admiring this lumen door here.
It's so, like, ambient and bright.
I know.
It's really bright.
It hurts my eyes.
Oh, this is so good.
It looks like a raw, like, shader on Blender or something.
The reflection is so intense.
Actual sun POV.
Yeah.
wash it down I'm gonna head over to I feel like it should be
an easier easier way you have like a McDonald's coloration
go and dogee oh yeah my yellow and red yeah what's the lore
attention the actions of the attached list of C group
scientists have been wholly disavowed by a corporate family
any subsequent actions from the group are noted to be
entirely unauthorized by our executive team fcorp cleaners
is imperative that you are successful and a complete purge
of all materials pertaining to their actions we value your
service all right so there's some that was not going on no
there was i was trying to bring the radio over to bludgeon
snuffy with it but you saved her what do these shapes mean
for god's sake they'll run across the what the platforms it
says oh it said don't do that i did that already like a
number of times oh well i hope it doesn't pay like i hope
you don't have radiation poisoning or something now it's
just a metal it's a suit i got a suit oh there's actually oh
there's actually a room below it if you if you run across oh
wait wait dokey come and stand on this which one yeah this
one next to me this one one where everybody's dead that one
seems okay no this one seems okay there's a hole dokey test
this rat trap yeah oh there's a guy dead yeah so i'm saying
the one where everyone Oh, surely it'll be fine.
No, I actually meant the one over on the side here, but you
can go down that one if you want.
But this is like extra clean.
We have to clean this up too.
Yeah, we, oh my God, this place is so dirty.
These guys are not professionals.
We're not going to get three stars.
We were too busy looking at bodies.
Barbara.
Oh, my God.
We've been leveling up.
Barbara?
And Barbara?
No, it's Barbara.
Hannah Barbara.
It's Barbara.
I know, guys.
I'm sorry.
at barbara wait what did you just whip this off where'd you
go how'd you do that how's wrong are you huh i've been going
out to the gym lately yeah i'm just doing a couple of
sprunkies just been doing a couple of uh she took crossfit
lessons at off guy yeah what is this see look at read read
her name read her name it's barbara barbara where are you oh
what's that noise oh barbara where is it barbara i want to
say barbara i think it's the guy that like gives us yeah
bananas oh yeah it's a banana man it's sean again it's
downstairs yeah i'm with sean oh he does like poop out like
things to clean i guess it gives up bananas it's like our
every time he does he's a nuisance we have to pick up goes
up yeah like i can break some of the stuff here and then you
can take out i think we're supposed to take out like the oh
it's because like i remember in the actual back rooms uh
that bent in the actual back rooms oh leak leak and the
sorry and the fake back rooms are not real guys uh what are
you talking about you sure you sound like you just exposed
like a secret government facility i know back rooms are
Guys, back rooms are just, like, made up on the internet,
guys.
What you saw, what you read is just all make-believe,
everybody.
But, like, in the original back rooms, there's no panels on
top of it.
So there were holes in the floor.
Oh, that was you.
Just as a heads-up.
Oh, oh, Jesus.
What is that?
Oh, shoot.
Not good.
Oh, they're, like, ladies.
Oh, it's fine.
There's a lot down here.
I feel like we don't have to clean it if, like, if it's
tough.
right you if you clean it you get like sigil power which
yeah you get the special power oh i see and eventually when
you buy our shoes it gives you like sigil power gives you
things like double jump i died oh no more i'm cleaning you
help thank you thanks yeah because like in the original
background back rooms uh it's just holes on the floor so
there's no like somebody's trying to safety proof it that's
this is all there is to be afraid of in the back rooms is
just like the floor i i know it kind of depends on like the
back rooms it depends on which where you are at in the back
rooms oh we got it that me oops all right i got oh okay we
need more of the oh my what's this say i keep thinking that
the ambient buzzing noise is the fan in my computer like
breaking i'm like oh my god what's that oh there's your
computer okay why are you accustomed to hearing such a
horrendous noise it's real no it's really quiet which is why
it was confusing I feel like Lamu's computer is always,
there's something, it's like haunted or some shit.
I know.
Michael, he's doing great.
I feel like always...
He's having a good time.
That's what you tell to someone that's dying.
They're having a good time.
They're having a good time, boo.
They're doing great, guys.
Nothing to worry about.
Yeah.
Or, Sigil Power is time seven.
Let's go.
What time is nine?
Oh, yeah.
Someone's slacking.
I probably died.
I mean, if you didn't slack off, you would...
Oh, oh, Sean.
Oh, the banana orb is back!
Sean!
Stop him!
We don't have...
I really like the noise that it makes.
I know.
Dump.
Oh, oops.
Are you one of those people that can stick their finger in
their mouth and make like the pop noise?
I can't do that.
Can you, Sufi?
No, no.
I can definitely not do that.
I would 100% try if I didn't have like sores in my mouth.
I don't even know how like did he do it.
it's something i don't know yeah i don't even know how
people do it i just seen them do it they just take their
finger like a baby and then they go yeah it's like i know i
know i know the concept behind it i just can't do it what's
the concept i know the math i know the science yeah try it i
want to hear try yeah like what's the concept what's the
concept though maybe we can do it after you teach us yeah
it's like for men to be a teacher and not like it's like
those who it's like those who like our acting coaches...
They themselves...
What did you do with the trash?
Are you like swinging it like a...
Can you bring the trash can down here?
Yeah, we kind of need to bring the trash can down here.
This is terrible.
I'm dropping it.
It's been dropped.
Drop it.
Beats dropped.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no.
Oh, it's really bright over here, though.
I don't want to see those.
Oh, no, it's the fucking spikes.
I think the spice ones.
Yeah, I think the spice ones are the worst.
Ooh.
Ah!
Oh, what the heck was that?
Oh, I thought I'd again.
Sorry.
I don't notice the orb is about to blow me up until it's too
late.
I'm too busy cleaning.
Wait, Stuffy, are you cleaning?
We got dead bodies down on the bottom floor.
Are you cleaning?
Are you cleaning them?
I'm cleaning.
No, we're dead.
We're dead.
We're dead down bottom.
We need help.
Yeah, help us.
Oh, are you all dead?
I'm going in.
Yeah.
are you guys uh the orbs that you're missing oh thank you oh
there you are thank you they were right next to you and you
didn't help them um i don't get paid to to revive people
literally a job right now our job is to clean not to revive
well you know this is why we don't want to be on a team with
you doki and you're what you mean i'm doing the objective i
am doing the objective showing your true colors yeah yeah
how is that i'm doing i'm doing which is what guys i just
killed myself what hell hell i don't even know but my new
name is worky hello worky first i hit the job i fell down
one of the hole and i crushed myself with a grate i think
there is some sort of like dang i didn't check it out check
it out there we go oh oh oh watch this guys um ow i'm gonna
do a three point with that pipe three point a uh back shot
off the rim 360 um corner shot trick shot bam first try okay
can you move it over here let's let's i think this game
would be improved actually yeah but every time you drop one
of these metal pipes it just did the pipe falling sound oh
my god over and over and over genius game dev ideas like the
popularity of those like like stocking game store games
except what's just like what's the stocking game store game
oh you know like there's like there's like movie simulator
movie store simulator car and shop simulator and grocery
store stocking oh yeah what if you have like metal pipe long
day at the the sound can someone help me kill the banana
dispenser oh gosh you in training i'm in training sorry i'm
doing my job someone jump into it jump into it i'll miss you
oh oh where'd you go where'd you go hello oh oh i'm back i'm
okay i'm back what happened what did you see my name is
merlin this is my first day of the job oh you died hey guys
can't wait to can't wait to meet all like get to know all
you guys it's my first day yeah i'm looking forward to a
long career together oh i hope you engage in as much fun
activity as the person before you yeah what i wonder what
happens what happens to the guy before me and oh no no way
he had a longest fulfilling career but decided to spend more
time with family how are we not done we have to throw the
greats there's there's trash above the greats I hate it down
here.
There's so much.
Hold on.
I'm gonna get that.
Yeah.
Guys, I might be gone.
Oh, hey guys.
Who's dead?
I'm not dead, and I'm in a lot of danger.
That'll be fine.
Just like the guy before me who retired and lived a long
way.
Oh, shams!
Oh, my gosh.
Why are you even going with the giant metal thing?
eating wild we're doing this well if we oh my god how am i
gonna get you oh we're gonna don't worry don't worry if i
just throw this in we'll be done it's okay no i'm gonna kill
you i'm my name is gabriel now hey gabriel hi now we have
more blood to clean up somebody pushed me into the spine we
have blood on the the bottom floor yeah we have blood
everywhere you spread it everywhere we could have been done
so much faster if you wouldn't oh my god you're making us
harder than for us man i'm so i'm so clumsy i just can't
face through a giant giant grate what are we missing oh
press tab it highlights everything you're missing oh you
left some blood splatters in the side oh oh can agree i was
trying to end it faster you ended me faster i didn't know i
didn't know you could be easily inflicted and pressed
between two large moving objects oh my god i don't know how
physics worked i didn't know they they just mattered so much
as all didn't you just die by like squashing yourself that's
true wasn't that a thing that just happened well now we know
we can kill each other yay friendship oh pick up range it
means you can pick up it means you can pick up more yeah oh
sounds wild where's the are you guys making fun of me no no
no we would never miss we'll never make fun of you this is a
nice safe place where nobody mocks anybody you already we
don't have to you know have to what ah nothing we just hit
level five if you go to this other computer you can now
unlock your super awesome level five ability wait when wow
wow wait we can double jump double jump or sigil stuff
really is that is that an is that a or choice i assume it is
i think it's an or choice no yeah can you can you switch you
can swap them you can swap okay okay cool yeah i think i
want an air dash all right air dashes i'm gonna do double
jump it's only in the air i think the ceiling is so low why
does it even matter yeah we don't know that there was some
stuff that was all the way above us there were some areas
that's like the ceilings were high above all right lord time
respected f-corp cleaners we're pleased to announce that d4
scouts have located a recent hideout of the prior members of
the c group science team your assistance is requested in
cleaning the location important the leadership team requests
the full description of the location in your post-mission
report while we cannot provide additional compensation for
this task family guys it's all about the corporal family
guys we're a family we're family you don't need more money
you don't need overtime guys we're family do it for the
family occasionally pizza parties cool i like a pizza party
it's on the other hand oh i found wait i found some there's
two here you go oh there you go there's some parkour oh i
think we're at the double jump for you need to be you can
you can use the ladders yeah you have to be yeah but there's
one of the other side we can't use them oh you can wait no i
think oh wait no we don't need a double jump it's like all
the way here all right there's a dead body here i'm throwing
pieces of metal off the ceiling i'm throwing no way you guys
might collapse all right i'm throwing missed yeah don't be
careful red yes there's a giant barrel that's gonna fall
down be ashamed of it crushes someone oh jesus whoa wait
someone actually left blood on there they're so clumsy oh my
gosh how do you even leave blood up there we're wearing
hazmash suit it should all be contained you know yeah i'm
throwing everything look what i can do which one are you
Watch this.
Where are you guys?
Oh, you're green.
Watch this.
Why are you at the top?
Oh, my God, cute.
Oh, oh.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, my God.
First witch, burn her.
Game of the game.
I'm not surfing.
Hell yeah.
What did you do?
She's surfed.
Jump on the barrel and then pick the barrel up and then try
and carry the barrel around.
Yeah, there you go.
I'm surfing.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
I'm...
I flew, I flew.
I can show you the word.
I did, I did see.
I got like, I was a beautiful witch.
Very proud.
Shining, shimmering, splendid.
I noticed that that barrel made some weird things happen to
me when I jumped down so I wanted to see.
Oh, this seems very stable.
Whoa.
In my head.
I'm putting all the trash on the floor.
Oh, wait, oh, don't wait.
but hey where is the trash bin oh it's over there i hear i
hear sean again oh it's sean the leash right side is a lemon
tree i think so i can't hit sean there are no lemon stealing
where's the room that's my guys he's somewhere up there you
have to get him guys he's dumping so much it's all right
sean will get tired silly sean he's gonna get tired he just
wants attention he just don't give it don't give him
attention just enable his behavior yeah okay he actually did
just disappear yes see that's what you do see yeah yeah all
right thank you guys for the good parenting lesson of course
of course just don't give your child any attention why why
is the couch with so much yeah it'll grow up to be a
well-adjusted uh individual isn't that what happened to
jeffrey dollmer he had no attention as a kid oh my god no
what are you trying to say no i the netflix show yeah he had
no attention as a kid no i think his dad just was like
affirmative on the bad stuff he he like he like killed an
animal and his dad was like that's so manly son you're epic
epic let epic animal kill son yeah he's like oh you have so
much masculine aspiration biology and bodily functions boys
will be boys i don't know that's what they did in the
netflix So I don't know how true that is.
Okay, but yeah, this is the Netflix Netflix show.
That's not like, like it.
That's like, uh, what's his name?
Like a high school musical guy, right?
Played him.
What?
What's high school musical with Jeffrey Dahmer?
Wait, was this, was Zach Ephraim Jeffrey Dahmer?
Unrelated to each other, man.
What?
I don't even remember who played.
Is that who plays him in the movie?
I don't know.
Was Zach Ephraim?
Jeffrey Dahmer?
Whoa!
Okay, I got poked.
already i mean honestly that seems kind of down there i'm
jeffrey dalmer isn't canon is it not guys no jeffrey
dalmer's a real person it's what is going on somebody said
we'll play them i thought zach effron was ted bundy oh ted
bond i'm getting my serial killer like that oh wait who died
me i got poop oh okay yikes that's kind of cringe kind of
cringe oh i'm sorry don't get poked again you're about to
get poked again
wait why are the these are all clean why are they guys i
don't know i think the metal thing is actually protecting
like one little bit there or something and i don't want to
around with it too all right i'll go i'll go oh you'll go oh
here you go i got that no but i read that wait i'm
The sigil power.
Oh, I died.
That's not a bad.
Can you help me?
Thanks.
Yeah, you guys did it.
Yeah.
Yeah, we got it.
Oh, my God.
Freya's back.
Guys, I'm free.
I'm free.
I'm free by the second.
Identity.
We've recycled through all possible lives.
Yeah.
I don't even clean that over there.
I think we have to get like these dilute the solvents and
dilute and some stuff on the wall not mix I'm pretty sure
Oh guys gravity is real in the back room I heard that I
heard that right behind me I turned around and wish you keel
over Hello I'm Tenebrae from Nebraska Tenebrae oh my god
Epic tales reference.
Why did they keep putting these sigils so far up?
It's so inconvenient.
Oh my god.
Please don't back rooms me.
I don't want to be back rooms right now.
You do not think about us.
Did you mix it?
No.
That's a...
I was just trying to have fun at the idol show.
Acids.
Right, they're just like...
Oh.
I like what oh shit.
Oh, I hear.
Sean's back.
Sean, why can't you quit us, Sean?
He's not throwing bananas this time.
He's throwing pots.
Oh, that's even more inconvenient.
Because you can at least pick up multiple bananas at a time.
You can't pick up multiple pots.
Sean's going through a phase right now.
Going through his pot phase, guys.
No, don't do drugs.
Don't do drugs!
Well, if you're in heaven, like...
He's in the background.
Do there's heaven to you?
Yeah, okay, I forgot.
He's, like, stuck in purgatory.
You can do drugs.
You can do whatever you want in heaven, you guys.
Yeah.
Where is your heaven?
There's a shotgun here.
Delete the evidence.
Why are there so many of these stinking sigils?
They're so annoying.
I know, I'm like, it's like footprints on the floor, on the
walls it's like maybe this is a giant footprint they're just
walking on the walls are we gonna have to face this guy
later face him like g-man the backroom's cleaner final boss
it's like race to clean i'm curious because on the computer
it shows like other levels so i'm curious if it does yeah
they're like there's there's pools and stuff i wonder we
could a vacation i wonder we skip levels and check after
this pools close oh oh there they are sigils right here oh
oh get this one get this one no it's the spikes where i got
this one i can't reach it no okay come on you go yeah you
just use it with your gun yeah okay we're good we're good
all right you guys i'm gonna just clean egg tie it's in my
head zombie I'm just gonna clean where this is a big ass
room like why are they songs stuck in your head they should
have brought some of the graffiti on the side I ran too fast
um can someone help me please oh I see you okay helping
thanks oh guys kids don't do drugs or you'll go into the
back rooms and then you have to clean the back rooms oh
shoot am I gonna die here no That'll be fine.
I'm bringing up more stuff to the floor.
Clean day.
Thank you.
I'm eating like a little rodent.
You're feeding me at the bottom of the barrel.
It has to be of an upgrade.
I got that one.
All right.
Where are these coming from?
Where?
What do you mean?
It must be like up at the top.
I think it's up at the top.
Everything at the top is clean, though, so it...
Oh, man.
I was so close.
Oh, my eyes are so green.
It's so green!
Oh my god, my eyes can't adjust to it.
I feel like I get teleported into another reality version.
Oh wait, do we have the double jump or whatever, and now or?
Do we have central power, yeah.
I don't have it.
Oh!
Apparently I missed a spot, guys.
She did not have central power.
I know I did.
I double jumped into the I don't see it.
Guys, I think you guys missed a spot here.
It's all on the floor, yeah, where someone died
mysteriously.
Oh, right, little tiny spots.
Right.
What else?
Throw that shit in here.
Someone picked it up.
You gotta throw it into the bin.
Where's the bin?
I mean, wait, where's the stuff?
Now, they're both down here.
They're both down here.
Everything?
I got it.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, three stars!
Three stars!
Yeah!
It's a green room.
Oh, my God.
Oh, hey, you got the green suit color.
It's a better green color.
Salmon.
Yes, Salmon.
It's green and pink.
Yeah.
Especially if you're gonna have a two-tone my suit.
You can, you can, you can, you can like, make your visor.
Like, like, like, oh, toxic piss.
Yeah.
Just like Doki.
Sorry, I just had to come in sick for work.
I took all my sick days already.
Ugh.
All right, weaponized nozzles.
Oh, we can...
Weaponized nozzle.
I'm going to get that, actually.
I'm going to get weaponized nozzle.
And then...
How much money do I have?
I have 2040.
I have 50% air control.
All right.
I'm looking at my upgrades.
Okay.
I feel like I'll do more nozzle power.
I'm going to go all in on nozzle.
I'm going to be an efficient cleaner.
I'm going to be made salmon.
All right, I'll check if we can do the pool.
Oh.
Or if we have to unlock it.
Oh, yeah, we might have to unlock it.
Oh, no, that.
Oh, yeah.
Do we?
Hile green.
That's what I mean to you.
Oh, there's mint.
Oh, there is mint.
No, we have to do Gold rating on peaceful One zero five
ladder Wait, that's literally what we just did One zero five
ladder That's literally what we just did I don't see which
one you're talking about The mint color That's green suit
color No, it says mint suit color I don't see Which one are
you looking at?
Which one are you?
The one that says Oh, peaceful
Okay, hi there boogaloo we're back oh wait what do we have
to achieve here it's peaceful mood oh no no wait no let's
not do it no no no it's okay no i already no it's okay we're
there's no essentials this time though so it's just oh i
don't want to do it again this level was annoying but you
wanted mint color no i want to go to the pool mom please i
want to go to the pool you can only pick one cleaning
boycott riot please okay okay let's drop dokey off the top
ledge yeah where is she yeah come here let's go beat her
with large objects i don't know you can you guys can like
beat me up and i'll just die i literally killed i literally
killed mint it's definitely yeah but it's like well you push
me off and into the into the you know into the true thing i
wonder if i can wait I mean, like, enough, like, ability to
move these around.
Can I even return the lobby?
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, there you go.
Uh, let's see.
Where's the...
Where's the door?
It's got to open up.
There it goes.
Oh, there you go.
The door?
Yeah, I asked permission.
Yeah, I asked consent.
Did someone say the door to darkness?
Alright, no.
Priority mission.
We regret to announce that a B Team Secure site has been
raided by a previously mentioned non-employee individual.
The site must be cleaned and any scientific materials binned
for archival.
Unlike with the prior F-Court mission, employees are not
authorized under any circumstances to study or read any
materials as they are confidential proprietary information.
Failure to comply with this request may result in
termination and legal action.
We can't read?
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, there's trees here.
Oh my God, cute.
That's cute.
This is nice.
I feel like you can see a body hanging over there.
Oh, my gosh.
See, you don't have a touch grass.
There's a house up there.
You can literally live in the back rooms.
I wonder if...
I don't think you should live in the back rooms.
I wonder if the back rooms have Wi-Fi or fiber.
They definitely have fiber?
They definitely have fiber.
They must have put, like, some data connection in the back
rooms, right?
Something awful and aggressive roaming the back room.
that will murder you.
Oh, there's a trash can.
Yeah, but like they gotta do something when there's nobody
there, you know?
Like, they gotta provide some entertainment for them.
Are you saying that the Cosmic Entities need enrichment?
I think the Cosmic Entities might have an iPhone.
Cosmic Entities?
I mean, there's PCs in the back rooms.
Like, why would you have PCs in the back rooms if you don't
have internet?
This looks like a LAN party.
I'm not gonna lie.
They have a LAN.
LAN at the back rooms.
Everybody land at the back rooms.
How do we get up there?
I assume it's older.
You just do it.
I'm up here.
In the movie, so yeah, like, I never really did much back
rooms lore.
I've only really engaged with SCP.
In the movie, they said that back rooms is, like, trying to
make copies of real things and making them less and less
perfect because it's a copy of a copy of a copy.
Is that, like, actual back rooms lore or is that movie lore?
It's, it's, uh, that's how Captain Clark came to it.
be oh wow there's a couple houses works in the movie i just
didn't know if that's like accurate well there's various
back rooms lore because it's like scps it's okay so it
depends it depends yeah that's why there's like rooms like
wasn't scp no what was that oh the back rooms wait was it
not is the back rooms is sort of i think something pushed me
you guys was it me push you it was probably like a giant
object that i swung around oh oh somebody's throwing stuff
at us it's me it's me oh you're red oh it is separate i
couldn't tell i feel like because a lot of like um a lot of
like internet like and what are they called like uh cryptics
are based off of scps cryptics it is true that's what that's
the word for it like i thought it was cryptids or is
cryptids i don't know english is my first language oh wow
i'm surfing again hold on i must i must go in an adventure
oh no it ate it oh don't worry sean's with me guys i got
sean i'm in the house what's in the house oh that house
reminds of that cabin game that you played oh i hated that
game was it scary or just bad it was scary oh i heard it was
like super short too it was very short yeah sorry what was
it it was like a one of those anomaly games but yeah you're
in the cabin yeah got you oh yeah oh yeah i'm missing i'm
making these i'm making these i'm throwing some i'm throwing
some guns here they're unregistered someone forgot guys
there's so much up here holy oh guns i thought you yeah oh i
lived what happened you fall you somebody wrecked their car
the back rooms what bozo the cabin factory oh yeah the cabin
factory i heard good things about the game just that it's
just short yeah yeah it is good don't get me wrong it's just
really spooky oh sounds good for a halloween it would be it
would be oh yeah halloween's coming yeah what do you hear
the new side oh wait you were playing lime you were playing
the new silent hill game is it good it's really really good
i i love it a lot atmosphericly it's It's so good because
it's like, they've so faithfully kind of like recreated what
like a UK town would be like.
Oh, it's also.
Guys, go to the, there's 20 sigils in the second floor and I
might need to be resed.
I need to be resed.
I think we're all dead.
Are we all dead?
No, no, no, no.
There's no way.
Lymo is still alive.
I see her.
She's cleaning right now.
I see her cleaning.
No, no.
Stop cleaning.
I was trying to kill a sigil.
stop cleaning why is this blue this is so scary what is that
oil oil that one sends you the blue one launches you oh oh
no okay now we're all dead i got i got fucked up but it went
underneath the wait wait who's that over there that's alive
me oh wait how did you live snuffy uh i don't know well i've
been with me died again i cut the floor dipping down is
screwing me over because i can't see where the edges of the
bombs are yeah it's okay stuffy you guys gotta live stuffy
you just gotta live stuffy i'm trying why'd there have to be
stinking who is this oh my god you guys should get res now
but you left a bunch of blood all right i'm taking over the
third floor now hey i was up there and you get to Yeah, New
Silent Hill's really, really good.
Look, I love how carried it is to a UK town.
It's very, very cool.
It looks really cool.
I saw someone complaining because they were like, this asset
looks like it was made in like, uh, in a PowerPoint, because
it was like, you know, it was like in a clinic, and then it
was like, welcome to the family clinic, and it was like clip
art stuff.
Yeah, but then it was like back in the day.
You know, that's legitimately, like, I could wander into a
random, like, small town family clinic right now and see a
sign exactly.
At least they're not using AI.
You know, at least this little family small business is not
using AI as all of them.
I mean, the game takes place in the 1990s.
Oh, no, I hate though.
I hate that, like, like, when I, recently a lot of, like,
restaurants have been using AI to display their show their
food.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, I'm like, I wonder what it actually looks like.
Like, when I order food.
Grimp it with, like, food trucks and stuff, I think.
because I'm like bro you just take a picture of the food you
made like it's not that it's not that difficult to do your
job is to cook just snap a photo on your iPhone uploaded is
that mop no that's not me yeah you should play the new
southern hill it's really I'm not playing the new southern
hill I'm yeah she's a cow no I am I am I am I'm not hiding
it I know I I know what I am it's not an insult because I
know it i i've oh my god oh my god oh my god oh okay sorry i
flew i flew i'm sorry that scared the crap out of me i'm
just curious because like i haven't heard much about this
new silent hell game uh they really didn't show like
anything about it that's what like yeah until it like
everybody was playing it so people are saying i saw negative
reviews though but it's just people saying like the they
don't have the specs for the silent hell game yeah no it's
negative reviews because they don't have specs for it like
because it's like very it's not optimized or some i feel
like that's a lot of triple-a gaming these days that nothing
has ever optimized i feel like it's just because like maybe
things are to run but that's because it's like really
beautiful like the only thing that i noticed is that there's
some traversal stutter but hopefully they'll fix that that's
just like you know ue 5 is it glory oh yeah it's a silent
hill game Okay, but maybe it's like imaginative with stuff
you ever played a Silent Hill game Yeah, yeah, I've played
two of them.
Yeah.
I played the room and I played There was one on the Wii Oh,
wait that one's good though.
Yeah.
Oh careful about saying the room though people say it's not
a real Silent Hill game Really?
I thought shattered memories was kind of a wild game.
Wait, why why is why is it not a real Silent Hill?
Oh shit guys a cabin guys the cabin got me the cabin got me
oh now it launches you now launch oh shoot why isn't it real
Silent Hill game I don't really some people just say it's
not the only Silent Hill game I played was the which one was
it the remastered Silent Hill 2 yeah I played 2 and 3 and
remastered 2 no I think people would have it was one of
those situations where when it first came out people were
really not a fan of it and now it's like fine what the heck
how is there more i i've cleaned this thing i fucked up i i
saw you oh my god double kill okay so who's still alive
who's still alive maybe you're the last one you're the last
one i am oh my god oh okay i'm the hero i'm the hero i
totally just walked into that still on the third floor guys
i don't want to just like stared at it tried to jump over it
didn't work yeah i saw you parkoring yeah okay there might
be a lot of blood now yeah my bad everyone clean up after
yourself clean up after yourself well my body's on the third
floor so i'm gonna head over there like here let's yeah the
only games i played was the shattered memories on the wee
which was kind of an interesting game because you it's like
an arcade game you like run a lot yeah you run forward a lot
and then the room which i don't know why that would would be
considered because i only have ever played the or i've only
played those two and i watched the silent hill movie oh it's
not the movie i don't which one it was i don't know which
one it was it was like there was a mom and she was looking
for her daughter yes the first one it's the first one don't
watch the other two there's i watched the newest one that
came out like, uh, I think like this year, it's, it's not
great.
It's not a good time.
I like how they were like, it's a triumphant return for the
Silent Hill franchise.
I actually really liked the original Silent Hill.
Oh, wait, I like the first one.
Yeah, the original Silent Hill.
Why am I throwing a chair?
Oh, excuse me.
I'm here.
Are you trying to kill me again?
No, you are burr.
No, this is just so obtuse.
Sorry, sorry.
She's trying to kill me.
She's reenacting the Netflix documentary she saw.
Why is this floppy disk moving around?
The floppy system.
I saw the original.
Because the newest movie was directed by the guy who did the
first movie.
So I thought it would be okay.
And he was like, we're going to make it amazing again.
No.
It was all CGI.
Mostly CGI.
It was so fucking weird.
I watched it with the dragoons.
And we were like, what the fuck is going on?
yeah i'm just gonna bring this upstairs is it even like he's
like i got him everybody's gone is it even like a like campy
kind of bad though like it's like silly um i guess i guess i
guess i guess if you want to see it that way but object of
power oh oh oh what are the containment protocols man i
think this is actually a target i just found like a target
you have to redact it yeah yeah it's fully redacted you
think we're redacted i want to play more control how far are
you where are you at right now uh i saved i saved philip you
saved philip totally saved him he's doing great he's amazing
he literally called me yesterday and said i hung out with my
kids they really love me it was his last day on the job he
was super excited to go home and enjoy retirement with his
family and then you know you know he did he did he did he
definitely did is he yeah lying lymu is she are you is she
lying no i guess you don't have to play the game i try to
play it i try to play it and then and then because you just
do because the video doesn't exist anymore and think what do
you mean the video doesn't exist oh shoot min think min
think
oh there's some explosion
let's just say the steam account associated with that
doesn't exist anymore min i'll give it to you i'm not
playing you guys are talking about i'm not playing from the
beginning i can't yeah i'm not playing from the v i'm not
replaying it it's a rough game to start over again it is i
agree yeah no i that's why i never finished alan wake 2 as
well i go it's because i'm so good it's because it was it's
it's so scary for me too and then i didn't want to why is it
scary it's a it's like a it's a spooky game you get scared
only context about alan wake 2 is me gushing about like a
particular section that's not scary at all so she's like
wait I know, yeah.
It was so, it's so fun and groovy.
No, no, it's actually a horror game.
Yeah, it's so, I think it was, it's definitely scary than
the first Alan Wake game.
And then, and then the thing is, like, I was at like, I
think like almost a halfway point.
Okay, who died?
I died.
I'm sorry.
I tried to, I tried to Mario jump.
Anyway, you say something about Alan Wake.
And it's a horror game.
It was like, like, how, I was, halfway on more than halfway
and then and then i never was able to finish it out and i my
child was like you should finish it i was like i don't guys
i don't want to replay it all the way and after the thing is
i have to i have to replay it on stream too because the vods
for it don't exist anymore so then so it would be weird if
i'd start in the middle of the playthrough like right it's
really good though i just i can i can't replay like watching
youtube like the dokeybird has two items in their pocket
dokeybird um no i don't the game told me the game told me no
i don't i think the game might be wrong lie malicious has an
item in their pocket i was picking it up to the fucking
floor to put it in the thing i literally just picked it up
dude you gotta you gotta watch those like youtube movies oh
yeah just watch it on his way
when we watch ourselves as you know i might actually do that
for alan week too because i i'm so mad because i was about
to get to the part where he does this the performance thing
wait wait that's the only way i play it dokey dokey when i
play it do you want to sit in with me i mean yeah i can sit
yeah i'll sit in then i can play it and you can just watch
yeah that's true there's my more people experiencing Alan
Wake.
That makes me happy.
Yes, commentary.
Yeah, why don't you even play it?
Are you playing it after control?
Yeah.
And then I have to wait until I beat the play resonance.
Oh, so you're going to control Alan Wake 2.
So you're doing it in order?
That's good.
Wait, is that the order?
Yeah.
The actual official game order?
It's, yeah, yeah, yeah.
it's kind of like max pain i guess then quantum break then
can then alan wake one then control then alan wake two oh my
god there's so many yeah she knows like the order in a full
order i've only known this game existed complicated i've
only known this game existed since i've seen limeu do the
dance segment i have no idea i think that's the best part
though about alan wake too the whole thing uh tunnels please
proceed to attach coordinates a full cleaning of the
location is required.
I'm upgrading.
It's especially critical to cover all objects in the
location regardless of an abnormal state or behavior.
Additionally, it is our pleasure to announce that we have
initiated a full review of F-Corp employee compensation
levels to be carried out over the next 14 months.
Your work is critical to our collective success.
Oh, we're getting compensation now, guys.
We're getting compensation the whole time.
Promotion.
We're getting promotion.
All right, guys, ready?
I'm going to be purple.
Yeah.
I'm gonna be purple.
All right.
I can do a couple more.
I'm strong.
We have two more and then we unlock a newer area.
Oh!
Wait, so we'll know where...
We'll know what happens.
Hard in my language.
Ooh.
guys remember to check out the sloppy sisters collab guys it
ends this week Gina draw sloppy sisters yeah join our
fraternity oh yeah we're talking about what are hazing what
how we haze how do we haze in our in our fraternity slash
sorority what would you do is it a fraternity or sorority
well fraternities for guys and sorority are for the girls
I'm one of the dudes yeah what would yours be i would
require people to crawl through a series of like of tubes
and tunnels to grab things like and whoever had the biggest
hoard at the end was that monster did you just copy monster
ink university like is that just modern university oh it's a
fair thing oh i can get it i need some help just just help
me get this through i can do it i can't touch it i can't
can't touch it.
You have to pull it out.
Are you having trouble finding the hole, Mint?
No, I got, I got through the hole.
I got through the hole.
It's a piggy bank.
I want to, I want to pour it up.
Okay, what would you guys do for your hazing?
Well, wait, I remember Mint was she'll go into the sewers.
I want to have a cult in the sewers.
Yeah, she wants to have a cult in the sewers.
Oh, yeah.
I see.
Based on a real story.
Yep.
Of the cult at her university.
Yeah, of the Ninja Turtle.
There were ninja turtles there.
Oh, yeah.
Donatello.
Michelangelo.
I thought you said Donatello twice.
I thought you were doing some sort of like, let's go in the
sewer and do like Bloody Mary with the ninja.
Donatello.
I'm trying to guess.
Be careful.
Summon Donatello.
I'm just saying three times.
Oh, my God.
Guys, there's a pizza.
Are you making fun?
fun of my religion or like that wasn't a spaghetti monster
religion or some shit wait this looks like a different level
already it's very different where are we we don't have
citric power why did they have like a like a whole arsenal
in here what's going on it's apparently nothing but garbage
it's about yeah we're getting rid of everything we don't
don't clean up after themselves oh my god these entities
rafael rafael did you see did you see like the series of of
tweets about like someone found like a themed ninja turtles
restaurant oh yeah i saw that they reply like the ninja
turtles yeah yeah because no because it's like they use ai
might like they use an ai voice to uh to take orders if you
call them Yeah, so people, and then they left the back,
like, they left a one-star review at the pizza place, being
like, I don't really want to give my information to an AI
Michelangelo.
And then, and then the guy, and then, okay, the worst part
is the restaurant, they're getting reviewed by, because
apparently the owner, like, he replied back, like, get on
with the times, AI is the future.
What?
Like, as a, as, like, a teenage male digital, like, my
teenager.
Yeah, as a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
Yeah, as a villain.
Is it like his OC or is he one of the Ninja Turtles?
I was like...
There's something that's like sickly ironic about the Ninja
Turtles being named after like famous artists.
It's just like AI like restaurant marketing.
Don't forget to get some visual power, we need it.
Oh, there's so many bombs!
Oh, I died.
Oh, don't worry.
Oh my gosh, there's so many now.
There's so many.
I have more of you if I'm safe.
We're so safe.
Oh my god, I died in your power.
Don't worry, don't worry.
My cleaning you, I get digital power.
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
I died again.
Oh my god, I'm hearing you.
I'm farming mid.
I'm farming mid right now.
I'm farming her.
I'm in like a really precarious area.
So please understand.
It's just giving me so much blood over there.
She's getting harmed.
I'm going to start cleaning.
this oh it's
fucked in here nope down there no oh my god always
backtracking a little bit there's no way we're getting
through this there's no way we got this guys i'm gonna start
cleaning men's blood right now okay it's like everywhere she
like splattered everywhere by the way there's my boy holy
shit how did you get on the wall i really i really screwed
up over and i'm glad you're only concerned about my blood
and not my well-being i mean you're alive there's so much
coffee here i know you need oh there is i i upgraded it okay
man did you get the upgrade where you give less blood when
you die i'll do the coffee i can pick up more things i was
just hoping He was, like, you know, pick up at the same
time, like, in Power Wash, where you hold the button in it.
I'm going to switch a bunch of things.
Go at the bottom and start cleaning your bodies.
I think I'm obsessed with that game, but, like, every other,
like, cleaning game I play now.
I'm like, well, it's not as good as Crime Scene Cleaner.
It's Crime Scene Cleaner is just so...
It does everything right.
This is just...
Like, what makes it...
What the better cleaning games?
It has, it has, like, a little, like, a ozone cleaner thing
that you can...
Ozone Cleaner?
So you can choose like a voice on it and like I choose the
psychopathic robot voice So I'll be like cleaning another
part of the house and I can just hear good voice.
Yeah, I can just hear going ha ha Everything be purged in
the other room.
Yeah.
It's really funny.
I should play that game.
It sounds fun It is.
I think I didn't fit I only played like I thought it was
just like a one-off game So I will played until like the
pool area No, you have to save your daughter.
It's got like a storyline here.
You got to save your daughter.
I didn't realize it had a full story.
I was just like...
It's honestly really good.
Yeah, it's like...
It's just power wash, but with an actual story.
But with a story, and I like the mechanics a little bit
better.
Yeah, me too.
I like the one that's like the Japanese cat or something.
I like...
The Japanese cat?
But I always try the DLC, so...
This is...
This is a crime scene.
It's the cleaner...
Yeah, it's the cleaner voice for the little robot.
You can make it...
like the top Japanese.
Oh, that's cute.
Yeah, it has, it has like a little, it'll be like, Sampai,
I'm cleaning.
Or like, I'm making your own, like, little maid.
It's got like a pretty heavy accent on it as well, so it's
really cute.
There's like a little, little maid cat cleaner.
Yeah.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I am the ceiling.
Zombie.
Zombie in your head.
Yeah.
You got that stuck in my head.
Zombie.
Oh my god, who keeps...
Who is not rubbing their shoes off the carpet?
Excuse me.
Donatello.
Michelatello.
Guys, we can't die.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
We're in like a minefield!
Oh my god!
This is the worst place for us to be in right now.
It's just everywhere!
Wait, there's like a...
I got you, I got you.
There's like a shield on it.
Hi.
Hey, welcome back.
Thanks.
Okay, now we're safe now.
We just don't, we can just ignore all the other stuff.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
There's like, there's shields on it now.
Yeah, that's why you need a spirit.
Just cleaning, just keep cleaning.
All right, two F-court.
Oh, there's some blood on the ground, though.
I tried any DLCs from the Power Wash Simulator.
I did the Shrek one, and I got...
Oh, I didn't Shrek one, too.
PTSD from it, like, cleaning DuLoc, and it was...
Oh, I cleaned DuLoc, too!
It took so long to clean DuLoc, and...
Oh, yeah, me too!
I think I...
I think I had a crash.
I lost my shit a little bit towards the end, and all I can
remember is my...
My chat found like a playlist or something.
Yeah.
And it had like, it had like a, I don't know, it was just
like this constantly repeating Chinese phrase.
And it was like, I don't know.
What was it?
It was like Hong Kong, Hong Kong 97 apparently, according to
my chat.
And it was just like this really annoying, like repeating
Chinese song.
And like, I was putting, I put that on.
I was like, you know, we're almost done.
I'll play this on repeat until we're done.
was a mistake it was it was a mistake we did we got gold oh
here you go i think we're promotion bound let me see the
song yeah this is the song this is the song i don't want to
know what that sound is yeah uh i'll put it in the collabs
channel here i i can play this on youtube yeah hong kong 97
for one hour hong kong 97.
Oh, I know this song!
Oh, I know this song, yeah!
I was cleaning Duloc to this for like an hour.
I was also humming the like the welcome to Duloc song to
myself and forgetting the lyrics.
We got new terminal thing.
We got new things.
Why is the back rooms vibrating?
I got a new one.
Every clear.
That's you up.
I don't know who went down together.
Maybe it's like it cleans for us.
I would assume so.
All right.
I think we after this next one, we get to unlock a new area.
I could at least power through it.
Oh, wait.
This is a boss fight.
I believe in it.
Let's we'll speedrun.
We'll speedrun.
Maximum priority.
cleaning requested.
Reports indicate that the attached coordinates are the only
location related to redacted that remain a non-pristine
state.
Please take an abundance of caution and know that you are an
irreplaceable member of our corporate family.
I don't really think that's true, right?
No, by accepting this task, you agreed to disavow all
knowledge and experiences related to your work, including
but not limited to, dimensional tunneling, null zero, and
sigil-based quantum encoding.
Are we all ready?
Yeah.
Well, let me change my color.
What the fuck was this?
Who's, who is?
Who is?
Who is, who is my swag?
Who is this clown?
Who invited this clown here?
If you guys like my look, it's similar to the Gina Draw
Snuffy collab bag.
W, W add, W add?
Yeah, yep, yep, yep.
Oh, this is a boss fight, guys.
Guys, this is a boss fight.
A boss fight?
Wait, really?
We must get sigil power to break the shield so we can kill
the boss.
Sweet.
Oh, there's a boss?
Yeah, look at this.
Look at the egg.
It's an orb.
Kill the orb.
Oh, my God!
It's a big meatball.
Big meatball.
Guys, have any of you guys played the new Halloween game
yet?
No.
What?
Halloween game?
or the game like the holiday no there's a new halloween game
by daylight except it's halloween it's like friday the 13th
too as well um but like i'm so sad because they removed the
the sex option they removed the sex option which is it's so
yeah like you know how in in like slasher films there's
always teenagers having sex and stuff because yeah or just
because they're sinners or whatever yeah and they had sex
yeah so in the game yeah so you could get power power ups by
banging someone in the closet.
And the thing is, they removed it because the implications.
You can play a very old man.
They removed it because they forgot to make him an exception
to the rule.
And especially because the character is, they decided to use
the face of the actual actor who played the character in the
movie.
So he looks like the real person and you can just like
cuddle up and get down and dirty in the closet with, you
know, actual game teenagers, which is...
I'm so upset.
that they finally included the most epic game mechanic and
they sloped it so bad.
Yeah, they took it out.
After day one, they took it out.
Let's have our characters be able to have sex, except let's
model them after real people and have their ages very great.
Oh, wow.
It's really funny because Loomis can do everything that the
teenagers can do, including, like, riding a bike.
So you've got this, like, 60-something, you're old men.
It looks really funny.
Booking it on a push bike.
People can't ride bikes in your life.
Yeah, after past 60, you are legally not allowed.
You know, you know, like how a teenager rides a BMX or
something.
Like they both can do.
And he rides it like that.
It's great.
No, he's young at heart.
Yeah.
He still has his whimsy.
I have sigil pie.
I'm going in.
I'm shutting it down right now.
One sigil down.
I got duck.
Whoa.
Like inside?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
There's like...
Oh, okay.
And then...
Oh, shoot.
That's it.
Oh, watch out.
Whoa, watch out.
They're everywhere.
Watch out.
Wait, Limo, you play...
You can double jump and stuff, you guys.
Oh, yeah.
You have the sigil power.
I got to clean up the song.
We are still listening.
You're such a song, guys.
what song are we fighting guys i think we're supposed to
fight the boss knows oh my god oh my god he's been a dirty
boy oh whoa i don't am i doing something oh he's getting
cleaned he's getting cleaned he's got a cleaner taking a
shower yes look at him look at his little spiny body in
there that's his aura we had to he's so small and Am I
hearing your dog?
Yes, you are.
Okay.
Oh, he does not want to take a shower, guys.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Anyone in my lap.
He upset he.
He's very upset.
You could hear the cat.
Oh.
No, we can't.
Is your...
Is your cat like...
Oh.
See what?
What are you trying to ask?
Well, you know, your other cat's inbred, so I'm so happy.
What?
You can't say that?
No, what does that mean?
I'm just curious.
I don't know, because I thought you had a thing for inbred
cats.
I mean, I can't lie.
It's not like I, you know.
I don't understand what the, like, are we referencing
something?
if her other cat's inbred yeah my other cat's inbred yeah
what do you mean i don't know i know she told me she don't
know where he came from but how do you know he's inbred if
you don't know my new cat my new oh new okay well well she
knows her other cat was inbred yeah i don't know if he is if
this one's inbred or not he could be okay what what size is
he showing what size is he how What is he not showing?
I took him to the vet today and they were like, he's a very
particular boy.
Like, peculiar boy is what they called him.
They were like, oh, wow, he's doing such interesting things.
He's like, what?
Like, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, explain.
He started juggling.
He gave him some toys and just the way he plays with them is
a little odd, I think.
Detail specifics?
I'm curious.
today that he really likes spring toys and he'll like take
them and carry them around in his mouth and then like do
like a backward shimmy with them that's cute dog yeah he's
like a dog he is like a dog yeah i had a cat that was like a
dog they're cute oh shoot spikies well it's usually because
they like also live with a dog too or like they might have
yeah oh hey guys that's me my blood oh i see you i see you
that's me in the corner there i might have got spiked with
you in the be wondering how i got yeah you might be
wondering how i met your mother oh shoot i almost died
surviving you somebody whispering no no what what are you
hearing stuffy i don't know somebody whispering but but lab
have you played the halloween game what do i have no i just
i experienced like most of it through clips and they were
really funny like they were who was like dedicatedly,
basically, like, role-playing as Limit.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
He's, like, riding around on the motorbike, like, Michael.
Michael, stop it.
Michael.
Yes, I saw that one, too.
Guys, we should play Halloween together.
It'd be fun.
Attack the entity!
Alright, but who's gonna be Michael, though?
Me, too.
I'm parkouring.
I'm attacking the entity.
Oh, he's almost dead.
He's basically dead.
I'm parkouring again.
I'm gonna check, go boy.
Yay!
Oh, we should bring over the laser beams.
Oh, ha ha.
Stop it, Michael.
Stop it.
I'm cleaning him.
Oh, it's scary.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, you guys are like- It's time, it's time.
Reach the safe room.
Reach the safe room!
Sorry.
I died!
Don't look back, don't look back!
Oh, shoot.
You keep going.
I'm sorry.
I'm Susie now.
Wait.
I'm not.
30 seconds to get there and it put me all the way at the
beginning.
This is messed up.
Someone has to make it.
One of us has to make it.
Oh, no, I'm so far back.
Oh, why did he...
Hi.
With my...
Did you guys make it?
Can you guys make it?
Wait, oh, I died again.
Don't worry.
I can make this.
Oh, man.
I'm Link!
I think we all made it, guys.
I'm also, like, super, like, super good.
I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna...
Yippee!
We all made it!
I also liked watching people like ride on the bicycle and
then like do trick spins into knocking Michael down.
It was really funny.
This game sounds awesome.
That's what I'm saying!
It's really funny to fuck around with with friends.
It's like not a good game, but it's a fun game.
Yeah, it's like lots of fun.
Oh man, why couldn't we have played this as the game, but we
could all, you know, like...
Because all of you guys are sick!
You're all sick.
True, true.
We got play this one.
You're all recovered.
And also, I have a tournament in two days.
I'm stressed out and I need a clean.
I...
Oh, do you stress clean as well?
I stress clean.
When I get mad, I clean.
Yeah, yeah, me too.
Well, I don't stress clean.
I stress clean virtually.
I do both.
Central power duration.
Oh, that sounds nice.
Oh, right.
I forgot about the seminars.
I was going to do that.
of a liquid i'm gonna do oh yeah i forgot about those two oh
i forgot about that as well well it's too late and cosmetics
waterfall development what the fuck there's what do they can
jump out of water when near the surface can swim faster i
think i i know what's coming next oh it's the pools open are
we going are we going to the pool i will see let me see
where we go now i should
Guys, I'm so sorry.
Guys, it might not be the pool, guys.
No, it's not.
It's not the pool.
I think we're heading to the pool.
Because the chapter's called Adrift.
Priority with Mission and F-Corp cleanup team.
We'll just try one.
We'll try one.
All right, we'll skip the lore.
I can do one.
One last job, guys.
Guys, this is not the job.
This is not the pool.
Wait, maybe we just have to turn corner.
Yeah, maybe we'll turn cornered in.
There'll be a pool.
There's like a pool right there.
Yeah, it's right.
Why did you just run around the circle?
I remember falling.
I don't think there's a pool.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, what?
John, you smell bad.
What?
Oh, you smell like poopy.
Oh, is that your cat?
Are you talking about your cat?
Yeah, he's in my lap.
He smells like poo.
Your cat's name is Johnny?
Yeah, his name is Johnny.
I got really confused because my editor's name is Johnny.
And I was like, this is weird.
Why do you name your cat Johnny?
Is there like a reference?
It's Metal Gear.
Of course it is.
There's a guy in Metal Gear that just shits himself all the
time.
I love him.
Yeah, his name is Johnny.
it's so funny that he smells like poop then I think it's
because he didn't I think it's because there's poop stuck on
his butt that could be any sat in my lap you sat on your lap
yeah this is it little baby he's just a baby he doesn't know
I think he knows here throw them at me I'll take them you
could be marking you throw them at me I wish you could like
touch the trash to the things and it destroys them it works
so we just have to like smear our bodies all over it and
grab everything just like johnny could i like just like this
into trash and have it work no that's what i was just saying
that i wish it did that that would be good yeah remove the
penalty for moving with it so i could have just like zoomed
all over the place scooping stuff yeah i tried in the first
level and realize you can't do that yeah same lame i'm
throwing some trash out on the floor Clean up all the...
No, stop!
Oh, it's gonna take a while.
Time is it?
It's not time.
It's gonna take a while.
We have a lot of trash in this one tiny room.
You know what?
I believe in Lyme Moon to take care of this.
Oh, fuck?
She's sick and you're still gonna put it on your shoulders.
I just assigned her one thing.
I'm delegating.
Who made you the delegator?
Um, I did.
This is my lobby.
I think we should have a pool.
Yeah, we don't even have a union.
We don't even have a swimming pool.
This is lame.
I know.
There were budget cuts.
We were promised a swimming pool, and it's just...
Yeah, but there's still time.
There's still time for to get a swimming pool.
It's okay.
have an idea mint leaves and makes a lobby and i'll go join
her lobby and you guys see her that works every time wait
how did we finish this level so far it's a baby level what
oh look why is that wait investigate the odd signal what's
that this it's an odd signal wait hold on i'm coming through
it's right here oh wait what hello hello is there lore in
this yes it is i've I'm reading the Lord the entire time.
I'll be listening to her.
We're the same part of the study I've never seen before.
We were chased by something and ended up down here somehow.
Do you guys want to hear Johnny?
Ducks.
They're ducks.
Oh, I hear Johnny.
Aww.
That's cute.
Oh, baby.
Oh.
But Johnny makes me feel so at home.
Oh, what are we doing?
Oh, well, you know.
Don't look back.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
I was playing with my cat.
Oh, my God.
To the pool.
Oh, where's the pool?
Oh, no.
Oh, it's the pool.
Where's the pool?
Wee.
This is nice.
I'm in the pool.
Wait, Lavo, Lavo.
There's the pool.
Oh, it was like an intermission.
I get it.
That's fine.
That's cute.
Oh, wait, you got, there's a new suit pattern.
Yes.
Yay.
Wait, wait.
This might not be one last job.
This will be the one last job.
Okay.
Oh, I know.
You can say no.
Oh, I'll do the pool level.
Oh, my God.
This is every.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, my God.
It's huge.
This is the lobby.
No, it's the lobby.
Oh, this is the lobby.
Oh, oh, cute.
I like how we moved all of our employee upgrade stuff into
this place.
Wait, that's so fun.
I like that.
Yeah.
I'm going to grab jump out of water, pyrups.
I feel like I might need that.
I'm stuck in the water.
I'm going to get a pattern.
Oh, I'm in the water.
Wait, you're swimming.
Look at you go.
How do you get out?
Oh, uh-oh.
Wait, you were supposed to tell.
Wait, oh, no.
What happened?
Hello?
You should buy the upgrade that lets you jump out of the
water.
Yeah, I bought that.
You have to go through the ladder otherwise.
There's an upgrade to let you get...
Yeah, yeah, I bought that.
Can I drown?
I'm gonna check.
I'm checking.
Why is my pattern?
How do you get the pattern to work?
Did you change the color of the pattern?
Because it starts in the same color as the same.
There you go.
I got it.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
There's a ladder?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Aren't we?
It's official in the movie?
Oh, it's horrible looking.
Oh my god.
The swimming area?
Oh, wow.
I don't think there was a swimming pool in the movie.
I think it was mostly just the actual, like, where we were
before.
It's just the back.
Well, they're probably making a sequel to the back room, so
maybe, maybe they'll add this pool.
I mean, there's, like, multiple rooms in the back rooms, but
everyone always thinks about the back rooms.
How the fuck do I select the mission?
mission computer it's not exploring there's so much to
explore here it's like in the by the other computers so this
one no that's the hazard suit front room oh there you go i
found it are you guys ready all right one last job everybody
one last one last i'm watching snuffy struggle to get out i
feel like a baby holy there's so many ducks and why is there
blood nobody could die in this area come on let's be real
but so what someone can run oh shit someone ran did that
like actually hold on hold still okay oh yeah you do flinch
wait what what happens that sound oh wait what's going on up
there oh that's where we fell whoa if you toss our job
checks of people they actually flinch wait really do try me
try me okay hold on wait i should wait oh that's too heavy
oh yeah there you go oh wait yeah
all right we're out cleaning the pool
okay here we go pool time pool time ducks ducks ducks wow oh
that says my name is randall some of these ducks are glowing
This is kind of fun.
Hold on, I'm reading Randall.
She has this hole.
This is Randall's hole.
Randall's hole.
Where?
Where are you?
Oh, it is.
My name is Randall.
Yeah.
Glad I'm- This is my hole.
Oh my god, that is his hole.
Right here.
Hold on.
I want to come look at your hole.
Give me a second.
He's presenting.
But wait, hold on for I am a hole.
I am a wiener?
I guess I'm allowed in there.
No, he's a hole.
I am a hole.
I will carry him any further.
Goodbye, buddy.
I love you.
This is depressing.
My name is Rand.
Oh my god, look, Ikea shelves.
I am a hole.
Two.
There's a fucking calic set up there.
Two way out.
Two out.
Way out.
My name is Ran.
I am a hole.
This is Trevor.
Get that one last.
I can't carry him any further.
Goodbye, buddy.
Sean is back.
Sean has followed us.
Oh, no.
It's mud orbs.
Kill the mud orbs.
They're spreading dirt everywhere.
I don't think it's mud, guys.
I think they just burst into dugs.
When you kill them, they burst into dugs.
the brown yeah muddy ducks too oh this is trevor he hits his
head i can't carry him any further goodbye buddy i love you
wow whoa yeah i was looking at that it's depressing it is
kind of depressing maybe he should have worn his non-slip
shoes and then he would be maybe he shouldn't have ran at
the pool they always yeah no running at the pool rule number
101 no he's being chased by like unknowable horrors uh well
he didn't include that in this yeah he should have wrote
that down so we wouldn't it should have been like he wasn't
uh he wasn't breaking the rules chased by unknowable horrors
yeah yeah yeah there are exceptions you know if he filed his
if he filed a complaint uh oh oh shoot all right well i'm
scared things to do at a trade station this is what What is
that?
Oh my god!
What the?
Oh no!
It like knocked me!
I was just executed!
Oh my god!
Bro, I guess everybody!
Wait, he's using ducks!
Oh my god, death by ducks!
It like, it homes it, it's like a homing thing.
It's crazy.
Help me too!
Help!
Got one?
Oh, I'm alive!
I'm alive!
Oh.
I'm on the lower floor if you can revive.
me oh my god oh my god i'm dodging i'm trying to get a thing
i'm getting ready i'm preparing myself for apex in two days
i got it we survive guys we're such a good team guys i died
died i'm no goose oh you're not gonna lie these shit ducks
are disgusting i'm goose my name is me goose no look at them
look at the brown ducks look at this look at this duck you
have to clean the duck oh you have to clean it what are you
talking about yeah clean the shit duck and then like put and
then you can pick it up no you really oh yeah clean the shit
duck oh you're right you have to clean it yeah tedious shit
duck i don't like it dirty boy he's a dirty it's just like
your cat yeah i know it is just like my cat you're prepping
yourself it's very relatable yeah maybe he'll have less ammo
if we get rid of the duck Oh, true.
He was picking up the ducks from the area, yeah.
Yeah, so we just have to throw away all the ducks.
Throw away the ducks?
Alright, I'm reloading, I'm reloading.
Oh, it's not clean yet.
It would do like little...
When ducks are clean.
Yeah.
Clean ducks, clean ducks.
This is a good... Oh.
More ducks and coming.
Duck shitter's coming in!
oh i'm too far oh shoot duck shitters i'm killing him oh
there's so many walnuts oh there's a donut walnut ew it's
getting it all over the wall it like smears yeah yeah oh the
orb like smears dirt everywhere and then like explodes into
ducks which then also smears dirt everywhere and you have to
clean them otherwise they become projectiles which there's
like yeah great level so many layers yes I'm just glad there
was the new thing though like as in like the one that was
spitting up bananas that's gonna be the thing now so oh no
I'm actually surprised there was like a different throwing
ducks and not hitting them inside the thing it's because it
was like bins so I was just throwing the pins someone threw
the cabinets in the on what don't throw a callaxes in the
pool not me not me what's a calix what's a cab it's a cab
but it's british oh oh you know the ikea shelf by name i
don't yeah they're besties like they made no they made them
they made a mod i have a задач but they made a mod and put
one in the sky room you can play oh yeah thank you oh where
is it coming from oh there right here we got all right we
just gotta get rid of all the duck oh wait there's the
Heisenberg duck right here where I want to see there I threw
it oh my god Heisenberg yeah it's Heisenberg duck oh where'd
you go I think I think I killed him oh my god there's more
ducks back here no there's still my name is Rand Doki bird
has three items in their I just picked up the duck I love
how this game
Malicious has an item in their pocket?
I literally just fucking picked it up.
Oh, that's what they are.
It doesn't matter.
Tell that to the game.
Yeah, yeah, the game says.
No, he's a hole.
I ole.
He's just celebrating.
Ole.
Oh, over there, yeah.
This tiny little scene right here.
Yay.
I'm honestly sorry.
shock that wasn't a three star i thought that was pretty
pretty i think it's because we also died yes dying to the
duct wow there's an f core right right yeah for really
really fast like a speaker whoa yeah model you employee yeah
wait we were like 50 uh 50 seconds away though from gold
star wow look how many points i got yeah whoa oh MVP.
Maybe you should play Friday Friday's tournament.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You guys were doing we were working so good together.
This was actually all practice for you to aim properly.
Yeah.
We were aim training.
This is like pre warm up.
Pre-gaming.
We're pre-gaming.
What's the one with the water?
Let's you jump out of the water.
Oh, it's a.
Can jump out of the water.
I like how Mint's upgrading us if we're going to do a part
two of this game.
Oh, well.
I mean, you never know.
Mint, I mean, you love this game so much.
Let's play this game again.
Wait, I bought my suit and everything.
I mean, to be fair, we don't want to waste that, honestly.
We don't want to waste the suit that you bought, the money
you invested already.
It's true.
we'll definitely play again it was fun i like i like it
though i think they're fun to do yeah i mean it's just like
it's like power wash simulator multiplayer but we're just in
the back rooms wait wait wait can you guys wait this is
gonna be freaking awesome you guys want to see something
sick okay watch yeah oh do it do it do it oh my god oh yeah
i need to get stuck
You're like the..
Mediocre.低!
Wait, there's other ones up there.
You guys try.
You guys, who does the best surf?
You guys the best surf.
You guys try.
There's other ones up there.
I'll be the judge Oh, drop Até's?
Oh, Min's doing it.
Oh, she's getting airtime.
She's getting... It's me!
Wait, that's live.
I'm doing it.
She's getting airtime.
Do it.
Yeah, me too.
Me too.
Oh my god.
show no i'm doing it i'm doing it this looks like a disney
ride i love it you guys look adorable up there oh no oh my
god she flew she served too close to the sun like that it's
fine i didn't want to be on the surfboard anyway i wanted to
be on the watermelon tube hey you guys are good at it what
the heck and sophie come on you just got any practice stuffy
i haven't okay okay oh who's that oh there's like absolutely
no resistance whatsoever the game's just like yeah let's do
it i killed you live next no crash we gotta we gotta freak
there was a freak accident at the pool
oh my god i still can't get out of the water even though i
have that upgrade Oh, joust.
You can't be jousting a bit.
I got too cocky.
I started going vertical.
I feel like we're like on a magic carpet ride right now.
I can show you the world.
Oh my god.
It's so horrific.
I'm just like watching you guys.
when I watch somebody like lose momentum and just sleep, my
heart is like, it sinks.
You can literally watch a car crash happening in front of
you.
I'm coming down for a graceful landing.
You ready?
Here we go.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, near.
Wow.
Oh my god.
Like a helicopter.
Oh, don't keep it.
Oh my god, don't leave.
Don't land.
Don't need it.
No.
Oh my god.
Limo could have the flew and not sleep for three days and
she could land a plane safely in an emergency.
Yippee!
The most reliable sloppy sister.
That was incredible.
This is liable at 1% power.
Is this me?
Is that you?
I know which one's me.
I know which one's me with that piss colored visor.
Wait, can we do like um what uh the weekend at freddy's
weekend at bernie yeah weekend at bernie hey guys it's me
i'm here part of the sloppy sister and i'm dokey bird i love
apex
that's so scary ew what are you doing dokey's dead body
They twerk when they're together like magnets.
We just can't help it.
Look at them go.
Bitch.
They're like trying to reach for each other.
This is so beautiful.
It's like a love story.
So baby, just say yes.
to bed i'm going to bed before we go before you go to bed
limo yes before you go to bed limo what should everybody
check out everybody should check out the sloppy sisters
merch drop it's ending on friday the 25th yeah you should
check it out go look go look at it it's really pretty
there's lots of high quality merch and you can support us
and that would make us happy yeah guys guys join our
Check it out!
Get it while it's hot and don't miss out.
Don't be late for class.
Yeah, don't be late.
Raging on Friday, everybody!
You may be not having your uniform, but very embarrassing.
Yeah.
And the teacher's not here in 10 minutes.
We get to leave.
That's true.
That's the law.
But thank you guys for playing.
Thank you, ladies.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, thank you everyone for watching guys next.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for your new Halloween guys next game
Yeah, yeah, yeah, let's all have sex in the closet.
Oh, we got really quiet Can we like can we like download a
previous version of the game?
Somebody's got to have like a mod patch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah The mod like bring the the sex mod bring it
back
Well, we can make it.
You guys.
Bye, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Stop me.
You continue your stream?
Were you going to go read Warrior Cats or something?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm going to continue for just a little bit.
Okay.
I'll read you in a second.
All right.
I'll see you guys.
Bye-bye.
See you guys.
Good night, guys.
Everybody.
Thank you.
guys for watching.
Please check out the Sloppy Sisters collab merch.
Okay, well, this is the Sloppy Sisters collab, but I'm at
the Sloppy Sisters collab merch.
Make sure to check it out.
It is ending in two days.
So check it out and support the Sloppy Sisters.
Let me spam the link real quick.
I have to work on the Apex tournament now, after now.
We're just finalizing the rules set and everything.
So the Apex tournament is going to be on Friday at 1 p.m.
PST.
I am still confirming teams right now.
And I don't even know who's going to be on my team because I
just want to make sure...
I just want to confirm everybody else's teams before I
confirm my team.
So, I just want to make sure everyone else is confirmed
before I worry about myself because I still need to figure
everything out and everything.
But game modes are all fully confirmed.
uh apparently we're gonna make we are gonna allow masters
plus players but we're gonna make master uh but it's only we
have like wild card matches so apparently the wild card
matches are uh that's nobody's name is super chat thank you
thank you good night dokie good night um i i look i i uh
watch gameplay of the wild card matches and apparently in
the new game mode for street fighter um you get to you can
use like street fighter six abilities so there's like
hadukin and stuff like that so uh so the masters plus
players the apex content creators who are in the tournament
they're not allowed to use any gun um but they can only use
the abilities in uh the wild card match like in the wild
card uh matches so like some of the abilities are hadukin
and like finishers and stuff like that um so uh so yeah um
that's the role that we implemented so like no melee
literally just They just gotta fight for their lives.
No guns.
Just melee and Street Fighter VI abilities.
But yeah, I think that's really it.
I have to confirm some stuff.
Make sure it confirm teammates, confirm teams.
Busy, busy, busy day for me.
Well, whoa.
Hey, guys.
Thank you all for watching.
Thank you for supporting Sloppy Sisters.
As always, I'm glad Sloppy Sisters wanted to do a collab
today.
and still uh you know and hanged out despite you know
everyone being sick i know snuffy had uh two fake uh and uh
lamu was of course sick because of expo um because there was
a patient zero at expo i also haven't eaten yet so i'm
getting my first meal after this stream um but i'm glad the
sloppy sisters uh we're down to um uh down to to join me for
the collab i can't wait to play actually really wanted to
play halloween too with them i'm glad nobody has played it
yet and so it'll be a fun new experience i'm wondering if we
should get a fifth person to play michael uh or do we have
like a random michael i know like because you can have a
custom room with five people um and uh i feel like it'd be
more fun if someone's michael so i don't know we should have
like one person like within the sloppy sisters someone will
be like one v3 or it should be or um I wish you had fifth
person in on the collab um but yeah anyway guys as always
everybody stay hydrated posture checked yep and we're around
to get that blood flowing if you stay up for us uh for me
and the sloppy sisters head to bed cause you deserve it I'll
see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye lots of work
to do now for me well bye bye everyone my